hey everyone welcome to this new digital
marketing course by simply learn in this
course we will cover what is digital
marketing types of digital marketing and
top 10 reasons to learn digital
marketing moving ahead we provide you
with complete digital marketing road map
skills required to become a successful
digital marketer next we will dive deep
into the various digital marketing
techniques like SEO social media
marketing paid marketing email marketing
and affl marketing we will end this
course by knowing top digital marketing
tools and most ask digital marketing
questions in an interview if you are an
aspiring digital marketer then have a
look at simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing obtain
certification as a digital marketing
professional through per University's
program acquire ire the knowledge to
develop and advertise your personal
website using engaging live Interactive
Learning sessions gain Proficiency in
fundamentals and advanced digital
marketing techniques by engaging with
Howard business publishing cases over 20
practical projects collaborative
interactions with chat GPT and AI tools
and access to more than 35 digital
marketing resources for admitting to
this course 2 years of experience is
preferred so hurry up and enroll Now
find the C Link in the description box
without any further delay over to our
tutors now let's see what digital
marketing is in simple words digital
marketing is the promotion of a product
or a brand through one or more forms of
electronic media such as Internet mobile
phones Google search engine marketing
Etc it's a way to reach client on time
and retain them with interactive
marketing using digital Technologies
also it is the most accessible easy to
use and contemporary method of promotion
which is also known as online marketing
so when we want to go and promote our
product or service using a campaign we
have different options so there are
different types of digital marketing
channels that we can choose from and
let's just go through that list of
digital marketing channels and the first
one is what I consider the king of them
all and that's SEO so SEO stands for
search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with SEO because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic on the search engines
including Google so depending on where
you're located in the US market Google
tends more has a large market share so
you want your pages on your website to
be found and clicked on organically and
so that means if somebody types in a
keyword you want that relevant page to
show up first on Google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people specifically in the
US but worldwide you search on a daily
basis so if you're ranking for those
relevant keywords you can imagine how
much traffic you can get okay so that's
SEO okay okay and here's an example so
you type in online shopping well you can
see the first listing here is a paid
search ad we're going to get to that in
a minute the second organically is
Amazon okay so online shopping you think
maybe Walmart you think maybe Alibaba or
you're thinking probably Amazon okay so
no surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for am Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay per click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsored search
or Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different names Anonymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw the previous example if you want
to be found for keyword you don't have
to worry about organic if you're willing
to pay for it you just bid on that
keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to appear number one in the
search results at the top of the page
for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well my
us.com is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually pairing
above Amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happen to clicked on that listing then
my us.com is going to pay Google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could be anywhere
from one p to $10000 it depends depends
on the keyword depends on who else is
bidding on the keyword depends on the
location depends on the time of day
depends on quality score there a lot of
factors involved and regarding what you
pay however the benefit of sem is
visibility and getting traffic to your
website for keywords you're not found
for so that's why sem is such a popular
choice for a lot of companies okay let's
talk about digital marketing that's a
traditional type of digital marketing
channel it's been around a long time you
know we all send emails on a daily basis
and we probably all receive emails on a
daily basis just is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you can send
your emails to a segmented audience okay
so if you have emails from females who
are 35 years of age to 44 that live in
say the southern part of the United
States you can segment that send them an
email and cater that email directly to
that audience and of course you can put
some nice call to action in there you
can design it really snazzy and you
could track it just like you can any
other digital marketing channel so email
is a very effective way to really reach
a target audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out you're
selling a product and the products
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let them know hey you have
until tonight to purchase product and if
you purchase it you're going to get 30%
off and you can put the coupon code
right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
emo marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a Salesforce of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
with the affiliate so that affiliate
could likely be a merchant him or
himself and they can basically be a good
partner of yours by publishing your
product or service on their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third party affiliate like CJ get
all these Affiliates to work for you
they're going to promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're going to pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me it's
a good way to you know really promote
your product or service and you can pick
and choose the Affiliates or the
Publishers of whom you want to work with
so here's an example of affiliate
marketing at work okay you basically see
a banner basically you could see earn up
to 12% advertising fees with AUST
trusted e-commerce leader okay so if
somebody clicked on that purchased for
example or joined you could pay out that
commission okay let's turn our attention
to social media marketing so social
media marketing you know I wouldn't say
it's fairly new I mean if I think about
it we're in
2019 and I remember talking about
Facebook back in 2006 so you're talking
about 13 14 15 years of social media
it's definitely evolved over the years
and but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on Pinterest or
Instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on Twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're going to promote but
we know social media can be effective
because people use social media I mean
Facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and and if you want to get
your product or service out there you
could certainly pay to have an ad on
Facebook or you could just post your
content organically okay that's the
beauty of social most of your Social
platforms like LinkedIn and Twitter and
Facebook and Pinterest and Instagram
they all have a paid form of advertising
that you can use to promote your product
or service or you can go the organic
route and you know post content
organically in hopes of driving traffic
back to your website so with social you
do have two options here but social is
interesting because there a lot of
different social media platforms out
there it really depends on your product
or service okay so an example of social
media marketing especially on Facebook
with Facebook you got mobile and desktop
and you obviously have the opportunity
to post something organically and have
that liked or commented on or shared or
you could post an ad and get that liked
commented or shared or clicked and have
people go back to your website and
fulfill the goal of what you want them
to do so moving on to content marketing
so content marketing is really an
effective way of really Distributing
valuable content online and when we talk
about content marketing you know we're
talking about different types of assets
so it could be simply text in the form
of a blog post or it could be a video or
it could be an an infographic or it
could be an image okay there are lots of
ways to create content these days
especially in digital marketing and the
great thing about content marketing is
you're writing content for a targeted
audience so if you're trying to targeted
audience on say Instagram then you know
who your audience is and you know what
the type of content you're going to post
on there so it could be in the form of a
video or infographic or just a graphic
and so that's the beauty of content
marketing really putting yourself out
there um and depending on the platform
putting yourself out there with various
types of content so for example we look
at YouTube you could see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on YouTube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps you the
company promoting your product or
service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you can do that
is via messaging you could do it via
email or you could be do it via an app
okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say Google ad as an example
and running your Google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bit adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to really promote your app
or your product or your service Via
mobile marketing digital marketing plays
an essential role in most businesses
today this has led to an increase in the
demand for digital marketing
professionals because of this many
people are interested in learning about
digital marketing it is becoming one of
the essential skills that you can have
if you learn how to use it you can make
a difference in your marketing
capabilities hey everyone I'm Tushar Bal
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this video we will discuss the top 10
reasons to learn digital marketing but
before we begin if you enjoy watching
Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay
tuned so without any further delay let's
get
started easy to start a career a career
in digital marketing is an easy one to
start the field is growing rapidly and
there is a demand for professionals who
can care the digital assets of a company
with this in mind it is easy to find a
position even with no specific degree it
is also easy to find further training in
digital marketing as a lot of free and
paid resources are
available a technical and creative field
both Technical and creative skills are
necessary for digital marketing it has a
lot of subfield hence it requires a
unique skill set and knowledge of the
latest technology for example a social
media marketing professional should know
how to run a successful campaign digital
marketing is a perfect career option for
those who are interested in both the
creative and Technical
Fields highly paid digital marketing is
one of the most popular and trending
Industries there is a v demand for
digital marketing professionals as a
result digital marketing roles are also
very well played your expertise could
help you gain better roles within your
organization which could improve your
salary according to Goldman sax report
digital marketing scope in the Indian
internet industry alone is expected to
reach us 160 billion by 2025 which shows
the extent of digital marketing in India
and the job demand for digital marketing
according to to glass door a digital
marketing manager earns around 7 lakh in
India and he she can earn roughly
$123,000 in the
US become an entrepreneur as a digital
marketer you will be familiar with wide
range of online tools and platforms you
can start a blog or website where you
can list your products or if you have
expertise in some field you can also
create your own digital products and
sell them online also you can start your
own freelancing business where you can
offer various services to the clients
all aspiring entrepreneurs need to
embrace digital marketing and even the
old ones need to adapt in order to
grow career growth there are lot of
digital marketing professionals around
but very few are skilled the demand for
digital marketing skills will increase
in the near future due to digital
economies rapid growth many individuals
are starting their online businesses and
almost every new company starts with an
online presence hence it's a per perf
chance for individuals who are looking
to make a career in digital
marketing the next reason is
versatility digital marketing offers a
variety of career options and a lifetime
learning since there are so many aspects
to it for example suppose you worked in
content marketing for 2 years and now
you want to work in SEO in that case
there is relatively little training you
need so it won't be that difficult to
switch over if you want to enter into
some other domain your digital marketing
experience will always be valuable
therefore it is said that digital
marketers can easily change
jobs the next major reason is more
number of jobs several new jobs were
created in the digital marketing field
after coid as most businesses came
online you will find many digital
marketing job opportunities on LinkedIn
every single day Grand View research
reports that the global digital
marketing software Market size was USD
56 billion in 2021 and is expected to to
grow at a compound annual growth rate
cagr of
19.1% from 2022 to
2030 the field of digital marketing is
vast however digital marketing is also
used in other areas such as blockchain
blockchain provides trustworthy metrics
for monitoring marketing campaigns in
real time it's also a good chance for
digital marketers to discover other
fields like blockchain time and cost
effective in the longterm digital
marketing will save you a lot of time
effort and money traditional marketing
is expensive and the cost keep Rising
there are cost of printing ads
television ads radio ads and billboards
digital marketing will give you more
profits than traditional marketing if
you know how to use it effectively
furthermore digital marketing requires
less efforts for example you can reach
Global audience using your laptop
sitting at home while traditional
marketing involves a lot of
efforts the next important Reon reason
is Recession Proof job Landing your
dream job is a rarity for many in this
job market with the economy still
struggling businesses are cutting jobs
left and right so how you can make
yourself Recession Proof if you are
creative and willing to learn it can
happen there are many ways to make
yourself more desirable to businesses
and get job offers however one way is to
become an expert in digital marketing
digital marketing is the internet-based
marketing of product and services using
digital Technologies mainly on the
internet marketing is an integral part
of any business with the ever growing
number of Internet users it is expected
that more companies will use digital
marketing extensively in the
future so now let's discuss the last and
interesting reason specialization the
field of digital marketing has a wide
range of
specializations SEO content marketing
influencer marketing sem and many other
fall under digital marketing an
individual has a lot to EXP explode and
once you explode you can pick a digital
marketing specialization according to
your interest additionally there is a
wide variety of skills that you need to
master under each of these categories
greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
from Simply learn happy New Year and
today we're going to talk about digital
marketing skills so digital marketing
allows business owners regardless of the
business nonprofit for-profit large or
small National local International to
really expand their business allows them
to personalize their content they could
save money and most importantly they can
measure the results and so that's what
we're going to focus on today when we
talk about digital marketing skills
focusing on measuring this results so
suppose anybody wants to work in
marketing or grow a company or help grow
an individual's company or ensure to
keep up with the appropriate skills this
is this is what we're going to cover
today so we're going to cover a few
channels and so let's get right to it
today we're going to start off with
search engine optimization or SEO also
known as organic search so
SEO is an interesting channel uh it's
probably the premier channel for most
companies in fact HubSpot confirms that
57% of B2B marketers stated that SEO
generates more leads than any other
marketing
initiative so it's really important for
not only just generating traffic but
it's also important for generating leads
and and generating more business
including e-commerce and so what does
SEO entail and what skills should you
acquire in order to manage SEO as a
marketing channel well if you think
about it SEO is really divvied up into
two pies one piie is called on page the
other pie is called off-page and so on
page consists of things you can do to
the website to help you be found in
organic search so what are those things
well it could be anything from you know
page load speed to 4 four errors to S
maps and so the point here is if you're
going to manage SEO and you know that
you got to make sure your websites and
tip Toop shape or your client's websites
in good enough shape for Google to
recognize it as a legitimate site you
have to have some technical skills now
I'm not saying you have to be developer
but at the same time you have to know
what a 44 eror is you know have to know
where and how to generate a site map and
upload that site map you need to know
how to edit a robot's text file so those
are you know what I call soft technical
skills but they're all valid for SEO so
you have to have some technical
background staying in the on page Pi
okay you need to make sure you have not
only skills to write content but skills
to optimize content so you need to be
aware of all the different elements on a
page in order to optimize that page so
again that entails you know some
copyrighting skills but more importantly
and probably more challenging is to take
those copyrighting skills and enhance
them for
okay so making sure that you're able to
understand what it is that you need to
do to get a page optimized so it can
rank higher in the search engine results
okay so those are onpage
skills then you got the other piece of
the pie which is off-page so
understanding you know what it takes to
make sure your site is relevant so it's
understanding different metrics off page
metrics like page Authority domain
Authority external links internal links
and so generally most SEO managers have
a thirdparty SEO platform that they work
with like sem rush or MZ so it's
understanding how to work with those
platforms to measure off-page results so
we always say that SEO as a digital
marketing channel is an 800 pound
gorilla well it is because you have on
page and off page to worry about so the
two of those together you know is is
quite a task in order to rank and so
what brings SEO and all digital
marketing channels is understanding the
metrics and understanding what you're
seeing in order to measure results and
improve upon those results okay so
that's really the theme for all these
digital marketing channels we're going
to talk about today it's really about
okay what metrics and how do I measure
the results and so when we look at SEO
in terms of measuring results on the
onpage side okay you're going to have to
do some keyword analysis you're going to
have to understand okay what volume is
you're going to understand how to get
the competition numbers okay and you're
going to have to understand what
keywords to choose okay so that in
itself is a skill being able to choose
keywords based on several metrics then
you're going to have to be able to
ascertain you know what pages and what
keywords are driving traffic and how
those pages are
performing okay and then again the off
page you got different metrics like
domain Authority or page Authority you
have external links internal links you
have no follow and follows and and you a
LW these little metrics related to
off-page SEO you're going to have to
understand what those metrics mean and
if you can to understand what those
metrics mean and then more importantly
act on those metrics then that's what's
going to help you improve your results
in terms of SEO so again that's going to
be the common theme here so I'm just
going to highlight again those metrics
that you're going to need to understand
in order to better manage SEO a channel
again on the on page side you need to
understand the technicalities involved
but for example page load what's a good
page load time what's a bad page load T
from a keyword perspective what's good
volume what's bad volume what's good
compet comption what's bad competition
so if you can understand the intricacies
of the measurements related to SEO then
that'll help you improve upon this big
Channel called organic search so SEO is
the practice of getting relevant traffic
to the website okay from organic search
results so it really is essential to
stay up
toate and have a complete knowledge of
the latest out algorithm updates and
factors that affect search engine
ranking okay so that's SEO let's
transition to search engine marketing
also known as paid search sponsored
search Google ads Bing ads payperclick
cost per click a lot of acronyms a lot
of ways to describe it at the end of the
day search engine marketing means that
hey you as an Advertiser have the
ability and have the opportunity to rank
at the very top of the Google search
results now it's different than SEO
because you're actually paying for the
placement and so to be found at the top
of the search engine results as a paid
placement or sponsored ad means that if
somebody clicks on your ad you're going
to pay Google X amount okay so unlike
SEO sem is very fast moving and so when
we talk about fast moving we mean that
you're collecting a lot of data very
quickly so sticking with the theme of
what skills should I have for search
engine marketing well if you're going to
collect data then that means you need to
measure the results of that data and so
sticking with our theme of measureing
results you need to understand first and
foremost what all the different metrics
mean related to centr engine marketing
okay so I'm just going to Rattle off if
you will a few of the metrics but the
commonality here is yes you can learn
what those metrics mean but you have to
act on those metrics so one of the the
main metrics involved with search engine
marketing is Impressions so impression
is just basically how many people have
seen your ad okay so if your ad shows up
on the search results page regardless of
whether somebody clicks on it or not
you're going to get an impression okay
so if you're getting a lot of
Impressions that means a lot of people
seen your ad what's a lot of impressions
well subjective okay so it could be a
thousand Impressions or 10,000
Impressions at the end of the day that's
how many people have seen your ad now
more
importantly you have another metric
called clicks clicks means how many
people actually saw your ad and then
clicked on your ad okay so if you have
100 people that have seen your ad and
one person who clicked on your ad then
you have a click through rate of
1% now when it comes to Google ads and
search engine Marketing in general you
want to have a high click to rate
especially on Google because that does
impact quality score so quality score is
another metric you need to be aware of
okay it's a quality score is simply a
number between one and 10 that's
assigned to each keyword okay so what
impacts quality score click through rate
is one of the factors that impact
quality score so if you
have 200 or 300 or 500 or a thousand
Impressions and very little clicks that
means your click through rate's going to
be low and if your clickr rate is going
to be low then your quality score is
going to be low and in order to pay less
to Google you need to make sure that
your quality score is good so you need
to understand the factors involved with
quality score you need to understand
Impressions clicks click the rate
because if you don't have a good click
theough rate then how do you improve
that so it's about measuring the results
and acting upon the results those are
the skills involved with search engine
marketing and that's just on the click
side you got the conversion side of the
house so you need to be able to
understand how to get
conversions and how to maintain a high
conversion rate so for example if you
have 100 clicks and only one
conversion that is a 1% conversion rate
okay fair enough but what are you paying
per conversion what's the cost per
conversion okay and if that number is
high like say $20 and you're only
selling a product that's say
$10 well then you got a problem and so
there's a lot of different metrics
involved with search engine marketing
you're collecting this data very quickly
so you need to be able to react to the
data that you see so that's the skill
set really involves search engine
marketing if you're getting the data if
it's a low click through rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion or very low Impressions you
need to be able to understand how to
react to what you're seeing and what
data you're collecting that to me is the
primary skill bottom line with search
engine marketing and there are other
skill sets involved don't get me wrong I
mean it's nice to be able to write copy
because with search engine
marketing typically the ads have very
few characters involved so you need to
be able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so writing Copy being able to
understand your target
audience um those are all things
involved with managing search engine
marketing but really the key component
here is again measuring the results okay
let's switch over to a traditional
marketing channel email marketing you
know one of my favorites you know listen
we're all bombarded with
emails uh and you know what it's it be
comes cumbersome at times I mean it's
easy to just disregard an email and so
to me the key here if you're going to do
email
marketing you need to have a certain set
of skill sets and so what that skill set
is is really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients you need to
hope that that email is relevant to that
audience okay so you need to be able to
really identify who it is we're sending
this email
too and a recent study done by
statista uh stated that 49% of consumers
really like to receive promotional
emails from their favorite Brands so if
you have a very strong brand then email
marketing is probably a good channel for
you if you don't have a strong brand or
nobody really knows about your brand or
your product or your business then email
marketing could be a little bit of a
steeper Hill to climb if you will but
really email marketing is it involves
emails that promote the brands products
and
services and if you could Target the
Right audience or making sure you have
the Right audience then you got a good
chance of having successful email
marketing
campaigns but when it comes to emails
you know it's like having a blank canvas
you can be as creative as you want as
long as you're talking to the audience
so the the big skill set here again is
copyrighting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copyrighting saying the right things but
not saying too much at the same time
making the email aesthetically pleasing
as possible so that when somebody does
open the email they're going to be able
to react to it so you know writing copy
with strong call to action or really
relevant copy that really talks to the
audience I mean those are all keys for
email marketing in my opinion
also one thing we didn't bring up in
search engine marketing but it certainly
holds true with search engine marketing
as well as email marketing and that's AB
testing and so AB testing is simply
taking an original and creating a
variant and testing the two to see which
one performs well you could certainly do
AB testing with email marketing that
means taking a subject line that has
traditionally worked for you or is
relevant for that audience and then
creating a variant or different subject
line so if I'm going to send an email to
100 people I'm going to send
50 people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variant
subject line and why is this important
because I want to be able to see what
people react to okay so if I see the
open rates higher for the variant versus
the traditional or the original subject
line then I know that this subject line
works and therefore I'm going to apply
this subject line moving forward and
then what am I going to do I'm going to
take it and test it against another
variant so you should always do AB
testing on subject lines so the concept
of AB testing should not be lost on any
digital marketer okay whether that be
SEO search engine marketing or email
marketing okay so you should have an
understanding of AB testing and of
course going back to measuring results
with email you have a different
different set of metrics we already
mentioned open rates so if you send out
100 emails how many people open the
email okay you want that open rate to be
as high as possible and then when they
open the email the people click on that
CTA or any of those links in the email
okay so you want a high click the rate
and then more importantly when they
click on a link in the email they're
going to go to a landing page you want
that person to engage with that Landing
page so what's the engagement rate of
the Lanny page from the email okay so
it's really important that you have an
understanding of all the different
metrics involved with email marketing
and again how to react to that data so
if you're getting a low open rate could
it be the subject line isn't that good
possibly that's why you have to do
testing if you're getting a low click to
rate on the emails that could be because
the copy may not be that great or the
design or the call to action or it's not
compelling enough for the recipient of
the email and then again the engagement
rate on the landing page if you have a
low engagement rate a low conversion
rate you got to look at that and figure
out how to improve that okay so you can
apply AB testing the landing page so
there are always ways to react to the
data regardless of what campaign or
regardless of what digital marketing
channel you're working in okay so that's
the commonality here one point on email
marketing is if you're going to measure
the results of the campaign whether
you're using you know vertical response
or mail champ or you know some other
email marketing platform you want to
make sure you have what we call UTM
tracking and if you're using Google
analytics having UTM tracking or
understanding what UTM tracking is
allows you to measure the results of
that email marketing campaign
in Google analytics so that's another
skill set you should have being able to
apply you know tracking to your digital
marketing campaigns including email okay
because if you don't it's going to be
hard to measure the results in Google
analytics so let's focus on one more
marketing channel here and that's social
media so we all know social media isn't
going anywhere it's becoming more and
more popular in fact you know offshoot
of social media is really influencer
marketing uh you know if somebody an
influencer has millions of likes on say
Tik Tok or Instagram you might want to
engage with that influencer and help you
promote your brand or your product isn't
that really what social media is it's a
platform whether that be you know
Facebook or or Twitter it's a it's a
platform to help you promote your brand
your product your services and it's a
chance for you to get to message your
user base your community perspective
clients people who don't don't even know
about your brand it's a chance to build
awareness so social media holds a lot of
different uh strategies if you will in
fact nearly almost 4 billion of the
world's population uses social media let
me see there's seven something billion
people in the world well that's a LGE
large percentage the majority of the
percentage of the world uses a social
media platform okay in fact just like
SEO where you need an SEO platform there
are plenty of social media platforms
there's later there's Sprout social
there's hoot site there's buffer in fact
buffer confirms that 73% of marketers
believe social media marketing has been
somewhat effective or very effective for
their business and that's promising
because social media in my opinion
having been in this industry a while it
can be a very fickle Channel meaning if
you're trying to promote a product or
service on
Facebook and it's very very going to be
very hard to pull that person away who's
engaged with their Facebook feed not
only just to get them away from the
Facebook feed onto your website but then
to turn around and allow that person to
try and
convert okay based on what you have on
your website so it's challenging enough
just to get them away from the social
media platform let alone converting so
that's why when I say very fickle but
you know somewhat encouraging if buffer
telling us that marketers believe that
social media marketing can be effective
and it can be effective you just have to
have the right strategy so to me one of
the skill sets you should have if you're
going to be a social media marketing
manager is being able to understand you
know what is the strategy here what are
we trying to to
achieve when we set up a social media
platform or enact a social media
campaign okay and so that's really the
first thing it's really understanding
what platforms what's the strategy here
because if the strategy is brand
awareness then what channels or social
media platforms if you will work best
for us is that Twitter is that Facebook
so it's being able to kind of formulate
a strategy a plan if you will for social
media marketing because the last thing
you want to do as a marketer is
endlessly just post content for the sake
of just posting content because just
like any other marketing channel you're
going to have
metrix and social media is not shy on
the metric front Okay so you have
reach you have Impressions you have
engagement rate in fact every social
media channel has its own set of
specific metric whether that be likes
followers shares uh uh reviews Stars if
you will so it really depends on the
social media platform that you're using
but at the end of the day you need to be
able to measure the results if you're
posting let's just say on
Facebook and your whole job or strategy
is to entice engagement meaning get
people to share that particular post or
act on that post then you need to be
able to measure the engagement how many
people saw the post how many people
engag with the post okay and so just
like any other marketing channel you're
collecting data and you need to react to
that data but more
importantly it's about being able to you
know put a strategy together
first and then I would you know a skill
set I would recommend you have is
understanding all the different social
media platforms that are out there you
know I just named buffer or hoot sweet
or Sprout social they're all good in
their own right but they're all going to
have different features so to
me understanding what social media
platform works best for you you want to
choose a social media platform that you
know allows you to control what post you
schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on at the same time you want a
social media platform that's going to
help you understand the engagement that
you're getting from that platform
and you probably want a social media
platform that allows you to quote
unquote listen in if you will on what
users are you know reacting to in terms
of hashtags or what's trending on that
particular platform okay so you want a
listening tool if you will uh as part of
that social media platform so it's
understanding what platform you want to
use when it comes to social media
marketing it's understanding what
strategy that that platform is going to
help you
enact okay and then it it's also that
social media platform that's going to
help you understand the data so you can
react to the
data so those are all to me the skill
sets you need as a social media manager
and then an offshoot of social media is
paid social so just like search engine
marketing you can advertise on say
Twitter LinkedIn Facebook on a cost per
click basis meaning if you're showing
your ad on LinkedIn and somebody clicks
on it you're going to pay for that click
you're going to pay LinkedIn or you're
going to pay Twitter you're going to pay
Facebook so it's understanding you know
the skill sets involved with paid social
is understanding what assets you can
have when advertising on these platforms
you know can you use video on LinkedIn
or
Facebook um you know can you use what
type of images and you know how big do
those images need to be and can you have
wording on those images or what are the
guidelines involved with having images
as part of your
ads so having a full understanding of
the types of assets that you can run in
terms of your advertising on social
media is very important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot forward when advertising on
social media and of course when you do
advertise again a whole another set of
metrics you know how many people saw
your ad how many people clicked on your
ad how many people engag with the
landing page how many people converted
what was the cost per conversion so all
of those are metrics that we covered in
search engine marketing they apply with
paid
social so you have the opportunity on
paid social you have the opportunity on
social media to to really get your
message out there it's really
understanding what kind of data you're
colleting cting what are the results of
the ad or the post and how do you react
to that and that's really the common
theme with digital marketing skills if
you're not a big fan of numbers you're
not a big fan of excel if you will or
spreadsheets if looking at a mountain of
data scares you well then you might want
to think otherwise when going into
digital marketing but if you want to
embrace the data then digital marketing
is really a great career because if you
can get the data and you know how to
react to the data then you can be
successful in any campaign you run
Rachel is a baker who runs her own
Bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
first setting up a Blog she began
posting on her blog regularly however
even after regularly posting on the blog
there were barely any visitors showing
up deciding not to give up Rachel began
searching for a solution on the internet
that's when she came across SEO or
search engine optimization a term she's
never heard before so let's take a
journey together and help her learn
about SEO search engine optimization is
a method that could improve the quality
and quantity of the audience coming to
Rachel's website from search engines it
could increase brand awareness attract
local customers and build credibility
and trust and all of this is possible
without having to spend a single penny
to bring visitors to our website Rachel
would have to take advantage of the two
types of SEO onpage and off-page SEO
Rachel first decides to tackle onpage
SEO and get that sorted onpage SEO
involved Rachel optimizing her website
both in terms of content and the
technical aspects including the HTML
source code schema metatags and more she
started off by using tools like Google
AdWords rref and and Sam rush to
identify popular Search terms associated
with the recipes she planned to publish
on her blog she began to look for Search
terms related to the broader area of
baking cooking and related topics once
she found these Search terms she began
to incorporate them into her recipes she
started off by providing an introduction
to the recipe with this she could
provide an engaging beginning to her
story like how the dish reminded her of
her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the Search terms in to
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
timelapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people after this she moved to the
website meta content that search engines
display when her blog appears in search
results she optimized The Meta tags alt
tags header Tags and More this completed
the onpage aspect of SEO thanks to this
she saw a significant increase in the
number of visitors coming to her page
having done all she could on her web
page she now decides to explore what
could be done off page to improve her
Page's visibility on search engines
off-page SEO involved Rachel doing
things outside her site page to help
increase its search engine rankings
making optimizations outside the site
would improve the site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and Authority
this is possible with the help of
reputable websites vouching for your
content with backlinks social media
marketing guest blogging linked UNL
brand mentions influencer marketing and
much more Rachel also understood that
for her content to reach people she
would have to promote it on social media
platforms like Facebook Twitter and
Instagram as well as Niche platforms
like a Reddit and medium these could
help her achieve greater reach for her
website by sending stronger social
signals to search engine
leading to the page being shown as
highly relevant for related searches and
audiences and even after understanding
and implementing all of this Rachel had
just scratched the surface of what was
possible with SEO before we find out
what she did next let's have a look at a
quiz which of the following is the most
effective way to improve off-page SEO
one creating plenty of web pages of a
Content two getting backlinks from
relevant and authoritative sites three
acquiring backlinks through link buying
four none of the above let us know your
answer in the comment section below for
a chance to win an Amazon voucher now
let's go back to Rachel Rachel decided
to take up simply learns digital
marketing certification with classes
covering just about everything she
needed to know about SEO it was only a
matter of time before Rachel began to
implement her learnings on her website
and see a massive uptick in the number
of viewers coming to her website in time
she could even earn money off the site
by setting up an online shop and with
that we've covered an introduction to
the concepts of SEO and the
possibilities it can open for you either
as a marketer or a business owner this
is Rob sanners from Simply learn and
today we're going to talk about keyword
research so what are we going to talk
about when we talk about keyword
research we're going to talk about why
we would do keyword research for SEO
we're going to talk about the types of
keyword that we need to research we're
going to talk about some methodologies
best practices on how to do keyword
research some alternate suggestions
we're going to talk about keyword
clustering and then we're going to talk
about some tools that you can use to do
your keyword research so let's start
with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipes step by step pizza recipes
with sausage home homemade pizza
toppings pizza dough recipes thin crust
pizzas she's doing a lot of different
topics on pizza recipes well what Jesse
needs to do is understand what's going
to drive traffic to these blog posts if
she's writing about you know different
topics around pizza recipes so she's
Unsure how these blogs are going to
drive traffic so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keyword to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care
and choosing the keywords to align with
your content so that's really the idea
why we would do keyword research because
some of the issues with keywords that
are poorly chosen are they could have
low search volume for example you may
choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it could be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
align with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me me that's the most important step
with SEO is keyword research so we're
going to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or longtail so let's
talk about short tail keywords first so
short tail keywords are keywords that
are usually three key wordss in a phrase
or shorter in some cases it may be two
key words in a phrase or shorter so the
short tail keywords usually have high
search volume which means likely means
higher competition but what it also
means it could be lower conversions
because short tail keywords like for
example pizza recipes could be
considered a short tail key word but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
shte keywords may not be as relevant so
if we compare it with longtail keywords
chances are you're going to have lower
competition that's one of the benefits
but you're also going to have lower
search volume but with longer tail
keywords the keyword is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rates likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short-tail keywords and longtail
keywords if you want to look at
simplistically short tail keywords are
Broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content as not relevant
versus longtail keywords that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while to rank
for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is Broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail key word that
may not be exactly what you're writing
about in your blog post so May draw a
lot of traffic but the traffic may not
do anything so the longer tail keywords
are very specific they consist of more
than three words in the search query
they have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long TI key word
is probably going to be greater because
not many other websites are trying to
rank for that same key word and so the
benefit of that is if you have let's
just say homemade pizza recipe with
mushrooms that's a long TIY word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic is going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than th key words
in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza dough
recipes so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
uh specific in nature longer tail so
these keywords are used for targeted
Pages including blog posts if you're
writing a blog post specifically about
pizza recipes with homemade dough then
this is the keyword you likely would
want to use versus just pizza recipes so
let's look at an example between a short
tail keyword and a long tail keyword and
to accentuate the differences we're
going to use Google's Keyword Planner
tool so Google's Keyword Planner to is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose p
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
going to click get results and what
Google's going to do is it's going to
show us the volume of those keywords so
for pizza recipe we could see the
average monthly search volume is
33,100 for pizza recipe so note that
pizza recipe and pizza recipes are
closely related keywords and so what
Google does is they can consider that a
close variance so meaning if somebody
ties in pizza recipe then they're also
in Google's eyes looking for pizza
recipes so it's a close variance and so
for the keyword pizza recipe which is
short tail we could see on average over
the past 12 months this keyword received
33,100 queries and so if we hover over
the graph we could see basically the
volume the average volume per month so
here I could see for this particular
keyword here the volume per month is 33
1,000 and then I can see the actual
volume over the past 12 months and then
for the longtail keyword I can see
homemade pizza dough recipe again close
variance homemade pizza dough recipes I
can see over the past 12 months what the
search volume is for this on average
it's 2400 but I could see here in
December the volume went up to 3600 but
for example in May it was 1900 so it's
going to fluctuate a bit over the past
12 months but on average it's about 2400
so shorter tail lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the differences between a short tail and
a longer tail and so what Google's
Keyword Planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here I can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords Fair fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of Google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2400 search queries for that keyword now
whether you get all 2400 clicks for that
keyword remains to be seen chances are
you're not going to get all 2400 you're
going to get a lion share of those
clicks but you're going to at least get
some volume on it so even the longer
take keywords have a lot of Promise CU
there is some search volume here for
this keyword how to do a proper keyword
research so we looked at Google's
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads and
we typed in two keywords and we were
able to get a sense of what the average
volume is so we definitely want to
choose key words based on the following
factors we want to choose it based on
search volume search volume is a good
indicator of the potential traffic we
can obtain so again for the key word
homemade pizza dough recipe we know that
it averages 2400 a month in search
volume again we may not get all 2400 but
are we're going to get a line share of
that we also need to look at competition
and so Google's Keyword Planner gives us
a high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
compet ition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what I want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
Google's Keyword Planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
I want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what I can do is go
into Google's search and I could type in
pizza recipes and I could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however that means that every
potential web page out there on the
internet that mentions pizza recipes is
going to be included in this number here
and so I want to get a better sense of
who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
I'm going to put in the all and tile
syntax and so what that is going to ask
Google to do is tell me all the web
sites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all in tile colon space then
pizza recipes my result drops down to
300 36,000 so what that tells me is that
there are 336,000 results with the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
now if I want to focus in on my other
keyword if I choose uh my other keyword
was a longer tail keyword homemade pizza
dough recipe so if I type that keyword
in so homemade pizza dough recipe or
recipes remember close variants and I
just click enter or type the keyword in
hit my enter key I'm going to get 35
Million results but again is that really
an indicator of the type of competition
I have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2,160 different results so here here I
can see the first result in the title
tag homemade pizza dough recipe second
one homemade pizza dough recipe so these
are sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33,100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 th000 so I'm going to
type in
683 th000 what was our next keyword well
it was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is400 so I'm going to
put 2400 in under my volume column and
then what was my competition well my
competition was I type that keyword back
in 2,1 60 so I'm going to put
2,160 so now I have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition I
have now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for number of keywords what
you do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition if I make that a
percentage I can see it's. 35% is the
ratio between volume and competition if
I do the same for my longer tail keyword
2400 / 2160 I can see that 111% so this
just kind of proves the point that yeah
I'm still going to get some volume but I
have a better chance of ranking for this
longer teal keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for number keywords and examine the
volume the competition and the ratio
between volume and competition for your
themed keywords in this case pizza
recipes so relevancy you want to choose
keywords that are very relevant to the
content that you're writing and then
again commercial intent what keywords
are going to drive more conversions and
revenue for the business so when we talk
about commercial intent we're talking
about you know are you choosing keywords
that are going to get somebody to do
what you want them to do so we could say
You Know download pizza dough recipes so
somebody's typing in the keyword
download pizza dough recipes then
chances are they're going to find you
come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular Trend going on
or seasonality so for example if I saw
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the Keyword Planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitle syntax
to find the competition so we entered
both of those numbers in and we get our
ratio and so when you have these numbers
for a number of different keywords you
want to be able to choose that ratio of
high volume low competition but always
relevancy always trumps ratio so always
go with a keyword that is going to be
relevant to your content don't choose a
keyword that's not relevant if you
choose a keyword that's not relevant
it's not going to bode well for user
engagement so the difficulty of a
keyword ranges from 0 to 100 and
Google's key keyword tool so it's going
to be easy it's going to be medium it's
going to be hard but my recommendation
is also to get the numerical factor and
that's the all and tile syntax and again
relevancy is what drives the traffic to
your website and keep the traffic there
on your website and also not only will
it keep the traffic on your website but
hopefully get that traffic to engage and
convert so that's the key about
relevancy you always want to choose
keyword that are relevant to your
content even if it's sacrificing volume
relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find key words
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those key words that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to to drive to your
site so some other examples like
commercial intent keywords or discount
deal your coupon shipping you don't
don't be afraid to use some of these
keywords as part of your longer tail
keyword phrase again the volume may not
be high but the traffic quality is
probably going to be better so keyword
research is the foundation for SEO so if
you have chosen your keywords properly
then if you do get ranked for those
keywords then it's going to lead to
better engagement with some conversions
and so when we talk about keywords we
also want to talk about our primary and
secondary keyword so every page should
have at least a primary keyword and then
a secondary keyword to work with so
primary keywords are really defining the
nature of your content the secondary
keywords are relevant to the primary
keyword so why do we choose a primary
and secondary keyword because you may
choose a keyword as a primary keyword
that is relevant to the content but may
not necessarily rank very high or have a
lot of volume that secondary keyword is
also relevant to the primary keyword but
also relevant to content and you may
rank for that secondary keyword so you
always want to go with two keywords
versus just one keyword want to give
your yourself a chance to rank for least
two different types of keywords of
relevant nature so for web page there
can be several secondary keywords but
only one primary keyword so your primary
keyword is always going to be relevant
to your content secondary keywords can
be relevant to the keyword but and you
may have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is direct directly related to the
content so that's what we're talking
about but these secondary keywords are
also related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to co Google's Keyword Planner
tool and get an idea of the volume for
healthy diet plan and then also the
volume and competition for some of these
secondary keywords like healthy diet for
weight loss healthy diet food low carb
diet healthy mail plans and diet plan
weight loss so if I go in to Google's
keyword planner and type those keywords
in I'm going to choose get results and
now here I could see healthy diet plan
keyword I'm focusing on is my primary
keyword has an average monthly search
volume of
99,900 and then some of my secondary
keywords healthy diet foods diet plan
weight loss low carb diet you know
Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan I go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan
99,900 what's my competition so my
competition is
74,700 and that's going to give me a
ratio of volume to competition of 133%
so that's what my content's about that's
a considered a short tail keyword
because it has has a lot of competition
and so my ratio is 133% and what I want
to do is I want to be able to put these
other secondary keywords in here as well
maybe even go to a little longer tail
because I want to be able to find two
key at least two keywords I want to be
able to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again of how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like Kora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social Med
media bookmarking like Reddit so there
are lots of suggestions that we can
obtain from various sources so let's
start with LSI keywords and LSI stands
for latent semantic insect indexing and
so basically what it is it's just
keywords that are linked to your primary
keyword and so when you're choosing
keywords you always want to choose that
primary keyword and then secondary
keywords that are similar to the primary
keyword and usually those are LSI or
latent semantic indexing type keywords
so they're used to drive relevant
traffic to your page so if you're
focusing on one keyword we want to have
other keywords that are similar to
increase our visibility on the search
engine result pages so we could find
latent semantic indexing write and
search so if we use the term healthy
diet if we go to Google search for
example if I type in healthy diet and
Google search all I need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and I can see
searches Rel related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other suggestions here so they're
saying lowfat diet veganism gluten-free
diet so there's lots of different
suggestions right in Google search bar
so all of these are LSI related keywords
so if you're optimizing a page for
healthy diet then you could choose
lowfat diet as a secondary keyword can
use gluten-free diet as a secondary
keyword it really depends on what the
content is but you always want to
support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so Google for
example uses LSI keywords to to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on Python and your content you want to
support that with LSI keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
found for featur sampit for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a keyword I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of questions
are being asked what meals are good for
weight loss what is a good healthy diet
plan all of these could be keyword
phrases that you can use so the answers
are right here in Google so core is a
great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions in a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good I it's a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
writing Kora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant key
wordss to healthy dieting so if you just
type in that particular keyword in Kora
you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get some
responses to the the topic healthy
dieting so what's the best diet for
Healthy Living what are the top five
tips for a healthy diet habit so all of
these could be keyword phrases that you
could take away with for your own
content and so the benefit here is
you're getting kind of an idea of what's
trending what people are talking about
and if you use tips for a healthy diet
habit for example and you optimize for
that well again that could turn around
and bode well for you because you could
be featured in Google as a featured
snippet at the top here you can also
turn around and use LSI related keywords
for healthy diet habits and you can
simply just look for those LSI keywords
right in Google remember at the bottom
or at the Top If I scroll down I can see
some related LSI keywords at the bottom
so writing Google as well you could see
in the Google search bar that Google
provides some LSI related keyword to
your query so if I go back here and type
in healthy diet recipes I can see here
Google suggesting some other related
keywords healthy diet men menu healthy
diet for men healthy diet foods healthy
diet for women so these are all LSI
related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
could be found at the top of Google and
they could be found at the bottom you
can also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
they're being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on Coral so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for term so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms terms
that people have typed in so if I go
back to Google again if I start to type
in recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages released
to healthy diet recipes I can also get
the search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google's going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google's going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
asset and use it to our own Advantage by
finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia we can
identify a list of keywords in The Meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the P paragraph of
Wikipedia that has many relevant
keywords or we could take a look at
keywords from the Wikipedia content
section so we can also see additional
Pages like the see also section that
gives relevant keywords that you're
looking for we can also look at the
references section as they contain
relevant keywords so if we go to
Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wikipedia here I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I can
see also section so it might give me
some information food information to
Consumers for example dietary guidelines
I can look at categories like dietetics
and diets I can also look at the
references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further than
first paragraph you go no further than
the SE also section the referencing
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you Google your keyword with Wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags
and the Ser so you can also do that as
well so if I type in healthy diet
Wikipedia and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantage or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for so Reddit it's a
popular Community where people post
content discuss a variety of topics so
that's what Reddit is so with the help
of subreddits an individual can find
relevant keywords with with high search
volume so and Reddit there's an easy way
to find out keywords they have a keyword
tool called keyword it so keyword it
ises the average monthly searches for a
particular keyword so if we type a Word
in key rdit and choose keywords from the
autogenerator list this tool will
extract the keywords and give us those
relevant terms with search volume so if
we go to the keyword it and Show an
example of that for example healthy food
if I get keywords I can see what
keywords are relevant and the search
volume of that keyword so if I just type
in healthy food keyworded tool is going
to tell me some relevant keywords and
what the volume is so if you don't have
the Keyword Planner tool in Google ads
available to you this is a good
alternative solution to finding keywords
so it's free you just need to go to
keyword it.com type in your keyword
click get keywords and what it's going
to do is give you some relevant keywords
related to your primary keyword with
these search volume let's talk about
keyword clustering now so the whole idea
about keyword clustering is to really
take advantage of the keywords that
we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme and that theme of
keywords is relevant to a specific page
of a website then we have a better
opportunity to rank so in other words
why do we have to Target just one
keyword when we can Target many so keep
in mind you know LSI keywords we want to
group a bunch of keywords together that
are similar for Content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is SEO how does SEO
work intro to SEO what are the basics of
SEO all of those are related to the
court theme what is SEO another cluster
of key wordss for example could be SEO
techniques SEO o best practices tips and
tricks website optimization onpage SEO
techniques Etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news so brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords
I.E a theme of keywords that you can
cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword SEO best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword MZ if I
go to keyword the keyword Explorer tool
in MZ and just type in in SEO best
practices what it's going to do is it's
going to give me some volume related to
that particular keyword but more
importantly what it's also going to do
is going to show me what pages are
already ranked for that particular
keyword so therefore I can get a sense
of who is already ranking for that
keyword so here I can see mzmz
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what web pages are ranked for a
particular keyword or group group of
keywords I want to rank for myself if
you are an aspiring digital marketer
then have a look at simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing two years of experience is
preferred so hurry up and enroll Now
find the C Link in the description
box hi guys welcome to the simply
learned live session on the top social
media marketing tips and tricks in 2020
now let's wait for a little bit as
people join
in so I'd like to thank all of you for
joining us from Facebook and from
YouTube and once again I'd like to
welcome everyone joining us for this
live session on the top social media
marketing tips and tricks in 2020 so
here's a reminder for all of you if you
have any questions regarding the topic
let us know in the live chat we have a
team here dedicated to answering all
your
questions now before we get into the
tips and tricks let's take a refresher
and see what exactly is social media
marketing social media marketing is one
of the most commonly used and lucrative
forms of digital marketing it's a
methodology that has Brands creating and
sharing content on social media
now if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it LinkedIn Facebook or
Instagram you've promptly been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that Burger King video
advertising their new whopper or about a
marketing tool that can help you
visualize your team's workload better
than any other in the market right now
one of these are just some of the many
ways that you've been marketed to and
the objective when it comes to social
media marketing is to achieve the
Brand's marketing and branding goals now
this could be increased engagement more
clicks conversions and so on so how do
they do it with text and image updates
videos or any other form of content they
can attract the users's attention and
can drive engagement from them now
alongside publishing quality content it
also involves analyzing your data and
running social media adver
advertisements now some of the more
popular social media platforms right now
are Facebook Instagram Twitter LinkedIn
and so on next let's talk about some of
the advantages of social media
marketing first off social media
marketing provides great brand awareness
now with the help of interactions with
people on social media brands are able
to build up their reput as businesses
and with each interaction each post each
share the brand is exposed to a larger
network of potential customers who might
be interested in the products or
services offered next it gives you more
traffic to your website marketing your
products or services on social media
will also attract customers to your
website outside of your usual customer
base next it improves your brands search
engine rankings now although this isn't
the direct correlation social media
marketing does have a part to play and
it comes in helping your page rank
higher up in the search engine rankings
now if you start posting high quality
content people will start liking and
sharing it and this will in turn bring
it to the attention of influencers
within the industry who would be willing
to write about your business and then
this gives you backlinks which as you
know will help you improve your search
Eng
rankings next it will give you improved
conversion rates and with your brand
being much more visible and interactive
on social media every text image video
or comment could potentially Drive users
to your website social media also
humanizes your brand now this leads to
more customers trusting a brand and
being more interested in your products
and
services and then we have improved
customer satisfaction when your
customers interact with your brand on
social media it provides you with an
opportunity to show compassion for your
customers personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand social media marketing is also
costeffective compared to other forms of
digital marketing social media marketing
offers some of the most flexible and
relatively lowcost options available now
this opens up your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures and
if you do get into paid advertising a
good strategy will net you a great
return on your
investment and finally it will help you
become thought Leaders with your
highquality posts communicating with
your audience sharing content and
promoting your Authority you can have
your followers look up to you and this
will allow you to become a figure of
expertise in your
industry now let's go into the social
media marketing tips and
tricks number one set up your
goals now what good will your actions do
if you don't have a goal in mind the
goal of your marketing strategy may be
the driving force behind every decision
that you make and this is exactly why
setting up goals is very important
moreover your marketing efforts have to
align with the goals of the
organization here are some things that
you need to keep in mind while setting
up your goals first of all your goals
need to be quantitative for example you
need to have a thousand conversions by
the end of the quarter or 5,000
followers on Instagram by the end of the
month and so on number two you need to
stick to a consistent deadline this
gives weight for each of your options
and number three make sure your goals
are smart now smart refers to specific
measurable attainable relevant and
time-based now let's go to number four
like I mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy and alongside these goals there
also needs to be the Northstar metric
now what is the Northstar metric well
this represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this Northstar
metric will also give your team Clarity
and
focus now let's have a look at some
popular northstars there's increased
engagement greater conversion rates more
leads generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two understanding
your
audience social media allows you to
interact engage and build relationships
with your Audience by understanding what
they need want and desire you can
deliver content in a way that makes your
product or service the answer that
they're looking
for there are also other ways that you
can understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of
Their audience by conversing with them
in forums responding to their comments
and blogs and social media taking up
their feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learns audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates an academy
has high school graduates and BYU app
has high school students as
users now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform now when performing social
media marketing choosing the right
platform is really
important When selecting them you need
to ask questions like why you're using
that particular platform who you will
reach with this platform what content
could work best on the platform and is
there any content that was unique to
that platform like for example YouTube
and then there's the
video answering these questions will
help you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest now let's talk about the
purpose of each of these platforms
LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences for
Facebook well just about everyone has an
account on on it content that is related
to news or entertainment usually finds
success on Facebook then we have
Instagram visual content works best on
Instagram now although it works well for
static images and short form video It
Doesn't Really drive a lot of traffic to
your website and then finally we have
Pinterest Pinterest is also limited to
static images however it's highly
effective at driving traffic to your
blog
now let's go to number four setting up a
social media
calendar a social media calendar demands
the message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform let's have a look at some of
the most popular types of posts on
social media first off we have
competitions now I'm sure all of you
have seen posts like tag a friend who
does this or comment or like to win
something and stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social media then
we have polls and surveys polls can help
you with if you need a collection that
also encourages followers to take action
and interact polls and surveys also
provide opportunities through which you
can learn from customers to understand
what they like about the product or
service or what they don't and to
receive their feedback and then we have
videos and live streams although we'll
be covering this in a little more detail
further on visual storytelling along
with videos and live streams goes a long
way to drive engagement among your
audience these will help get your
followers attention increase trust and
credibility and have a high response
rate and has so much more to offer live
stream with its live nature and having a
human face alongside your business
humanizes your brand and by extension
helps increase customer loyalty and
trust and then there is infographics
articles and images so social media
calendars are successful because of
their ability to increase collaboration
within the team help understand what
works and what doesn't and in
distributing resources in an effective
manner next up we have number five using
social media marketing
tools social media marketing tools align
to the goals of your organization with
it you can create highquality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement and it also helps you
with the planning process you can plan
create and schedule posts on your social
calendar now some of the more popular
social media tools include buffer hoot
site Buzz Sumo if T and much
more hello everyone welcome to this new
video by simply learn search engine
optimization has been playing an
essential role in the success of various
businesses for those who are still
looking for growth in the industry and
have search engine optimization
otherwise known as SEO as their Prim AR
weapon then yes you are in the right
place this video on how to rank number
one on Google will give you the best
tips to get a higher ranking without
spending a penny but before we begin
subscribe to our Channel simply learn
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so before we
begin I have a question for you the
process of getting the quality and
quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look at the top five
mantras on how to get ranked number one
on Google search result pages and while
understanding this we will put a light
on why these success tips are important
for getting a good ranking and how we
can actually implement it we will share
some necessary tools to help you carry
out the needed process and stick to the
end of this video to find out the one
thing that can impact your business
tfold so definitely we're going to take
a look at the best tips for ranking high
on Google but before that it is
necessary to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google well we
are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business the
data states that around
1.17 billion people across the globe use
Google search which is estimated to
increase exponentially in the coming
years moreover Google has gained the
trust of their users with their services
over the years this definitely makes the
point of interest to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google search
ranking at the top of search engine
result pages also known as CS allows a
business to generate more traffic to
their site and possibly get more leads
by which then they can get a chance to
convert leads into customers thereby
boosting sales it also helps in
generating authenticity for your
business well not one or two there are
numerous reasons which makes SEO
important to know more about SEO check
the complete playlist on SEO you can
find the link to the playlist in the
description box below to gain expertise
in search engine optimization get
certified as a skilled SEO professional
with simply learns search engine
optimization training course you can
check the course details from the link
in the description box below as we know
how important it is to rank high on
Google so in the next 10 minutes let's
get to know the top five success mantras
that will help you rank high in Google
so the fifth tip on our list is promote
your content whether you are a business
owner or a blogger you definitely need
to promote your content to get a good
audience reach by content here we mean
data on your website that can be
products services or even a simple blog
to do this find the relevant groups on
the social media platforms like Facebook
or Instagram and post your content with
an excellent call to action context some
blogging or article submission sites
like Kora Tumblr and hub pages may also
prove helpful online forums and
communities can be a good option to
spread a word about your content with
people having similar interests let's
focus on our number four tip internal
linking a good site architecture is
always a happy bite for webcrawlers a
website with good site architecture and
internal linking helps webcrawlers
understand the website structure and
helps them to crawl the site more
effectively the more the pages of your
website are crawled greater are the
chances of getting indexed if pages are
successfully indexed they get eligible
for appearing in the search results
let's move to our tip number three yes
it is backlink building any website
linking to your website is a backlink
for your website websites with more
backlinks suggest to the search engine
crawlers that that website has good
content and is trustworthy and should be
ranked higher on the search result pages
to get a backlink the most important
thing is to understand that the da or
the domain authority of the website for
which you are looking for the backlink
is greater than yours getting backlinks
is somewhat entirely a gesture of
Goodwill you can find a page relevant to
your business and ask the website owner
to add the link to your website to the
page in a humble manner you can create a
better or updated version of some other
web content let the site owner know
about it and then ask for a backlink and
a humble way yes you can find some more
relevant backlink building techniques in
the video how to build backlinks check
out the link in the description box
below at number two we have a tip which
is of utmost importance to win a good
position in the search results onpage
optimization onpage optimization or also
known as onpage SEO is a process in
which we take essential measures to
improve the website or web Page's
position in search engine rankings
onpage optimization is a vast concept
that includes technical optimization of
websites like server speed page loading
speed removing page errors submitting
Pages for indexing and more maintaining
a good website structure and improving
it adding internal and external links on
the site adding SEO optimized images and
video on the page efficient use of
keywords on the page and links and much
more get the detail guide to learning
onpage optimization by simply learn
check the link in the description box
below and finally the best tip we have
is the most effective one and the one
that rules them all which is keyword
research keyword research is a process
of identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create proper keyword research
may prove a boon to your business but it
also has the power to ruin your business
so be wise When selecting your keywords
try choosing longtail keywords if you
are new to the business as these are
easier to rank for you can look at
Google's Autos suggest feature to
understand what people are looking for
in your industry be updated with what
your competitors are doing if something
is working for your competitor there are
High chances that it may work for you as
well you can also take the help of
various keyword research tools like
Google's own Keyword Planner answer the
public tool Google Trends and Etc these
fantastic and 100% practical tips can
drive your business to Heights make sure
you implement all these tips with more
detailed attention as SEO can make and
break you so what according to you is
the most effective way to grow your
business online let us know in the
comments below hey guys welcome to
today's session my name is Sachin seal
and I'm here to talk about a very
important tool Google ads and out of all
the ads we can create under Google ads
today we would be talking about a very
important one Google search ad so this
is going to be very exciting this is
going to be very deep from my experience
I can say I will going to take you
through a lot of technical aspects and
lot of uh optim optimization strategies
where you can really bring down the cost
down if you're really paying high for
your clicks and conversion so please be
with me and I would try to give you the
best from my site great so let's just
start guys Google ads is something which
we have discussed in the last class if
you have seen my last session if you
have not we will leave the link in the
description where we talked about the
basics of Google ads and we also talked
about how to create this beautiful ad
account or a tool with a free Gmail ID
okay we did talked about few more things
that how many types of ads you can
create just to give you the quick
Glimpse we are on Google and when we
type something like if I want to do a
data analytics
course so I would type few things like a
word or a key or a quiry into Google
search engine and then Google as a
search engine would would show me few
results the results which we see on the
top we are talking about these today you
know this is the topic or this is the
kind of an ad which we would create
today in this session this is called
text ad or this is also called Google
search ad okay so this is the first type
of an ad you see or which you can create
under the Google ads there are few more
just like if you would go and search for
any of the e-commerce product probably
by
winter
jacket
online so then there would be results
but in a different shape and color and
different structure there is an ad which
is a text ad but on the top we are able
to see some more ads but they are not
just text they have a pricing they have
a title they have a brand name they have
a image of the product so they are
called shopping ads or product listing
ads in addition to that sometimes you
know when you go to a product uh a
website like speed test and you see the
product ads
there but again in the different shape
and color so they are called display ads
because they've been displayed on
different websites and different apps so
why I'm going so fast in explaining you
different type of ads because as I told
you we have another video created uh
with the name of uh Google ads for
beginners 2023 you can just check the
link in the description and you will
able to get all this type of ads and
whatever the uh you know bidding
strategies to be used in basic in that
particular tutorial or that demo just as
to show you if you can see that adds by
Google so this is the display ad or a
banner just quickly I have shown you
three types of the ads but our Focus as
I said today going to be on a very
specific ad which is the most important
ad from the Google ads family okay so
let's just begin
guys when I come to Google ads this is
how the Google ads structure looks
like we have a Google ads account
created again I repeat if you don't know
how to create it please find the link in
the description to create the Google ads
account once the Google ads account
created then you would have a dashboard
like this okay in this dashboard you can
see there are campaigns there are ad
groups there are ads there are videos
there are landing pages so a lot of
things can be confusing if you are just
coming to this account or to this
beautiful tool for the very first time
so to just keep it very simple or to
explain in uh in a very simpler way what
I did is I just drawn this structure for
you okay so the structure says that you
have a Google ads account imagine that I
am a simply learn Google ads manager so
I'm am running the ads for all simply
learn keywords like data analytics
course digital marketing course or any
machine learning course python course so
whenever somebody types this so there is
a ad which shows like from Simply learn
probably we have to just assume because
currently I'm not able to see any simply
learn ad here so data analytics course
India and then probably we can see if
there are any you can always change the
keywords but just to test I'm uh
randomly changing the words or I could
have just written simply Lear
specifically because I want to go with
simply learn only I have researched a
lot and I feel like this is one of the
best okay so probably there is no add
though still I will
check probably have to just change the
codes so I will go for the another
course which is by simply learn again
and then probably we we can expect any
of the ads
running because this is not a very peak
time so we are probably you know saving
some of the cost not running the ads at
this odd hour anyhow so we can assume
that this is the ad you know I'm am
running for so how we can create this ad
how we can get the best of clicks as I
said it is not a very best time to run
the ad so this is also kind of a change
you know we can bring into our ads by
doing some research so how all these
things are done we're going to be
learning it okay so when we come here to
the dashboard and then we see our
dashboard looks like this a bit
complicated so we can be confused we can
be disheartened that I have created the
account by seeing uh the first video but
now I am all stuck okay so probably I
have to again wait so the wait is over
now we are here to understand the whole
structure okay so let me just take a
very simple example suppose I uh I'm
someone who's selling a shoes okay
because I have just said simply done
probably let's just convert it to any of
the Google ads account of a a shoe
seller probably I'm Nike okay and I am
making the ad for Nike shoes and I am
selling uh two types of the Nike shoes
today probably formal or Canvas OR
probably I'm selling the casual or any
sports shoes and what I did I created
the campaign named it search ad uh any
month you know whatever the month you
have started with suppose November so
November 2022 that is the name which I'm
giving name can be changed name is
something which is being put it up for
my reference so that after creating lot
of campaigns I'm not confused in which
campaign I have to check the results
okay so I'm running the search ad for
shoes for the month of February or
November or December 22 23 whatever and
then I open two ad groups into it why
I'm opening two ad groups under one
campaign because I'm selling two kind of
products under the shoes only I'm
selling formal also under the shoes only
I'm selling casual also so what happens
suppose
I would have just you know created one
at group and would have inserted or
submitted all the keywords of formal and
Casual inside one ad group then if
somebody would have searched a term
called formal black shoes then this ad
group would have got confused that
should I show formal ad shoes or should
I show casual ad shoes because what I
did I have just got all my keywords like
formal casual Cricket shopping jogging
party office you know all the mixed of
the keywords from formal and Casual
family into the same ad group the moment
any of these six keywords being typed or
being searched on Google then this ad
group would have got triggered and then
again randomly it would have shown the
ad of a formal or ad of a casual because
both of the ads would have been under
this okay but after doing uh this bif
foration or after doing this
segmentation what would happen all the
formal keywords like party shoes office
shoes formal shoes formal black shoes
would go here this ad group would
trigger if any of this keyword would
searched and accordingly this ad which
has everything related to only formal
shoes will be shown and of course with
that ad the landing page which is
connected which uh would be open you
know when somebody clicks the ad okay
and Wisa Versa if somebody would have
searched for a casual term like a casual
shoes sports shoes jogging shoes running
shoes then this ad group would have
triggered and then the casual shoes ad
with all the headline related to that
casual keywords would have been shown
and accordingly if somebody would have
clicked then the landing page of casual
shows uh you know would have opened okay
so if this is clear actually you are
very much ready to uh dive into the
Google ads because many people takes a
lot of time to understand the structure
because uh you know maybe they are very
much confused at the ad group level but
I have just tried my level best by
bringing this example why I am creating
two different ad groups why I'm not just
going with the same ad group you know
mixing all the
keywords second scenario could have been
or a second permutation could have been
I would have just you know probably
created two different campaigns all
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only the only this part would
have belong to the first campaign then I
would have created a different campaign
Al together and I would have named it
campaign search ad casual shoes November
then this second campaign or a second
campaign can be assumed here with you
know with a green color would have been
drawn okay so this is how on the
structure it works like we can always
now create inside so let's just see few
things uh before we create the ad okay
very important uh requirement or rather
I would say uh if being the campaign
manager of any any any any any company
you name any startup you name or any
client you work with or probably for
yourself as well you have to be very
much sure how these terms works like
Okay so this terms when I talk about is
going to be bit inclined towards the CH
today only and when I talk about the
display ad in the next video then I
would you know take you through about
the terminologies and all the kpis of
display Banner or a video ads okay so
now if I talk about a search ad a very
important um term which we should be
aware of is the maximum bid price okay
because we all know when we talking
about this ad which is called a text ad
then we are paying on every click okay
that's why this is also called PPC ad
this is is also called PPC marketing or
you can understand in a very simple
words uh Advertiser which uh is emiritus
this in this particular ad only has to
pay when somebody like such In This
Moment clicking this ad I click this ad
I reach to the landing page of this uh
particular University or this college
and a certain amount is deducted from
this particular ad account and that
certain amount actually decides or
decided did on the basis of the keyword
helped to show this ad okay so as an
Advertiser must have paid something to
Google ads for showing this ad for this
keyword okay so when I say a maximum bit
price it means it's a maximum bid price
of a keyword that's why now this would
be easier to understand by this example
suppose I want to run the ad on the term
called data analytics course
2022 what I did I have opened the Google
Keyword Planner you know I did talked
about this in the previous session but I
will take you through again how you use
a Keyword Planner smartly so I have got
this data from the keywords planner that
the average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ad is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I have bided something over
the minimum bit price okay this is the
minimum bit price this is the maximum
bit price okay and this is what I've got
from the Keyword Planner so rather than
going for a very high price or the
maximum bit price to secure my position
I want to play safe and what I would do
I would just take U chance maybe 30 40%
over the minimum bid range and then I
will see if the Impressions or clicks
are coming or not if this starts coming
it means that my ad is accepted and my
keyword is you know winning in the
auction and I'm able to get the clicks
but if it is not picking then certainly
I have to increase my bit price but
coming back to the terminologies what we
talking here is once I have seted up my
maximum bit price of 7 rupees then my ad
would start showing suppose my ad shows
for thousand times today and every time
when my ad been clicked you know certain
amount being deducted there is a
competition there are other advertisers
also you know who are running the ad and
after showing my ad for the whole day
Google in the dashboard just shown that
you have paid average CPC of 5 rupees
only so I bid it for seven but by seeing
different uh you know factors like the
competition the demand and how many
times the ads got clicked what was the
position where my ad was shown I ended
up in paying 5 rupees for every Click by
the end of a day so the average CPC
sometimes you know people get confused
the average CPC and the maximum bid
price the same no so maximum bid price
is something which I uh you know submit
to Google that this is the maximum I can
pay for my add to show on certain
keyword for every click and have a CPC
is something which actually you know I
pay every day or you know in that
average of the duration your ad got
displayed or got clicks uh for every uh
click on that particular keyword okay or
the number of keywords if you have more
than one keyword uh submitted and
suppose I've got 100 clicks then you
know it's a simple math that my budget
which which I have spent today is 5
rupees for one click 500 rupees for 100
click so daily budget would be 500
rupees and tomorrow if company says I
need 300 clicks then of course my uh
average CPC which I have from the
historical date of yesterday you know I
would just do my maths and I will going
to submit the daily budget of not 100
rather 300 today so that in, 1500 I can
expect 300 clicks at the cost of 5
rupees per click okay so this is a very
simple of the example to just make you
explain how things works you know you
submit something then on the basis of a
lot of factors you know Google
calculates Google gives you clicks and
once you have the data then you know you
can just understand how this all is
working okay last thing before we dive
into the tool is Keyword Planner so I
just told you we have done in the last
class how this works like so we go into
tool and setting and then we go into
Keyword Planner I'll show you in the
account also the Google ads account just
after 30 seconds uh the screenshots over
so your Keyword Planner opens and then
you discover the keyword suppose I am
selling data analytics course so I would
just put my search term data analytics
codes and then I'll click the get result
and then accordingly it will show me lot
of options and this is the pricing I was
talking about it gives me the low price
and the high price so I would take the
30 40% over the low bid price or the
average price between these both and
that would be my maximum bid price and
and after checking all the permutations
Google would show my ad or either it
would not show my ad also there can be a
chance so I have to just wait for my
impression and clicks and the results by
the end of a day and I would you know I
would know uh how much the average CPC
actually I'm paying for each keyword
okay so I'll show you all those reports
in a while uh that's it right now let's
just go and see few things so the
Keyword Planner will start with suppose
I start um you know in researching all
these things my campaign is about data
analytics course I'm making it for
simply and I would go and I would just
try to you know search into planning my
Keyword Planner and then I will write a
term quickly here you know whatever I
want to show my ad for suppose data
analytics course as I
said okay probably let's say digital
marketing we because we would have
more uh results so it's easy to
understand with a lot of results because
I would be able to tell you how to sort
and filter them down uh digal marketing
course and you can just test it with any
of the keywords I'm just doing a random
check so once we are here we have lot of
keywords in addition to what we have
submitted so the keyword which I have
provided is this and the result shows
that it had over 100k
uh you know um monthly searches and uh
of course in the range of 1 million in
the in the you know in the month of 2021
to September 2022 so this is actually
the average monthly searches happened in
between this period and uh the advertis
is actually paid as low as 44 Rupees to
as high uh 224 rupees okay that can
easily be uh you know converted to
dollars uh half a dollar or maybe more
than half a dollar uh 60 70 cents
probably and uh this is like going to be
a $3 cost okay so what we can do is we
can see now there are a lot of keywords
been given and we can easily sort them
down here on certain you know uh basis
like you know suppose the monthly
searches are high or the bid is low and
all that stuff but this is quite you
know difficult when we have to sort down
here in the Keyword Planner so what I do
is I'm just going to talk about the same
you know like high how I actually go
when I working for my clients okay I
have clients here a lot of clients I
don't want to show you but yeah I have
and um suppose I just go and download
this data from here and then this would
be you know uh downloaded in the Excel
format and we can just save it anywhere
suppose I just bring it here and then
now I would open the keyword
sheet and I would have a data in my
Excel okay so I need this this one so
this is the most important column
because I have to highlight uh which
column is important and what is not
required right now so whatever is
required I'm just be keeping with me and
what I feel like is not very important
as of now I'm just not going to be
taking them so now there are five column
which I have kept with myself like these
four where we talk about the
results and the keyword okay uh this is
not required this is not required I'm
just going to be deleting or hiding them
okay so when we talk about a competition
index value so this actually tells us
that a particular keyword is how much um
you know from the competition point of
view is difficult to rank suppose I talk
about two key ones right now let me just
take um one with a lower score suppose
this one and I would take the higher or
the highest one probably is this one
okay so now when I talk about a comp
comparison you know probably uh or or
probably let's say this this one because
this has monthly searches which are
equivalent uh you know from the uh
competition point of view they are very
differ but the search has been same so
if I would stuck to something of this
sort that if I have to finalize between
these two so what I would do you know
that that's something which we are
talking here you know if we have a kind
of a combination where we have to decide
out of these two so both of uh the
keywords mean very important if I would
just check from my n ey a quick Scan
they look very promising they look very
great to me suppose and they have a
equivalent number of searches in the
last uh you know one year on the average
monthly basis but there is a difference
between the competition okay now people
can be confused what is this competition
so I would just make you explain in a
very simple way Suppose there are 100
companies or there are 100 you know at
Tech institutes or probably physical
institutes who teaches uh digital
marketing because we are doing online
marketing or you know digital marketing
course online sir so let's keep it uh
online uh institutes like simply Lear
and all okay so what they have done is
in the last one year they all have used
these keywords to run their ads you know
to show their uh advertisement or their
digital ad on a Google space okay when
this data has been given so this is
telling me that out of those 100
advertisers or my 100 competitor
66 or a
66% advertisers have used this ad okay
or have used this keyword to show their
ad okay and out of 100 33% or if it is
100 uh then 33 advertisers have used
this keyword to show their ad okay so it
brings you know kind of a uh comparison
to US that probably these two keywords
are very much in demand you know like
equally from the searches point of view
because both have been searched equally
but whenever this has been searched then
there has been a competition where 66
people or 66 advertisers or 66%
advertisers are fighting to show their
ad okay and when this keyword been seed
as equally then only 33% or 33 people or
33 advertisers are fighting to show
their ad on Google space okay when I
talk about 100 then that seems to be
okay where my ad would look like you
know where my ad would show because if I
just go on a Google space you know that
only seven ads are shown when you know
when we go on a Google search engine 1 2
3 and four and then the rest three would
be at the bottom if they are shown at
this moment or not I'm not very sure so
three would be here somewhere so total
seven adds placement on the first page
nobody goes beyond on first we know that
97 of the worldwide audience don't don't
go beyond the first page in nation okay
so we have to be on our first page so if
I talk about from the first page seven
positions point of view it would make
more sense so let's imagine there are
only 10 advertisers of digital marketing
course so out of 10 if I take out 66 66%
then it means almost like six to seven
advertisers are fighting or have bided
or probably are
trying to outrank each other to show
their ad on the top or on the first four
positions of Google but when I talk
about this then only three to four
advertisers are fighting or have bidded
for this keyword to show the ad on the
first page so this actually is a very
important data sometimes we just you
know Miss it because uh it has not been
uh I think explained anywhere else that
what exactly this value is we only go by
the low medium high which is the very
first First Column I delete nowadays you
know I don't you know go by this because
they both come under the medium but
there's a big difference you know seven
out of 10 would have been bided for and
only three to four would have been bided
for this keyword so never go by the high
medium or low just go by the index value
because that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best search keyword
with the you know kind of index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bid
value or a bid uh price which is also on
a very lower side not a very high price
keyw would we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that much uh you know we go for the
high search keyword and then we'll try
to get the low medium competition
keywords which of course less than 60
index value and then I put a price you
know kind of a price of my price you
know which is like if the low bid price
is 10 Rupees then I just make it 13 by
adding 30% to it so if the pricing is 10
so I would add 30% to it that makes my
price 13 and then I check you know uh if
the first day if the Impressions has
come it means my price actually been
accepted but if any of the keyword my
price is not accepted then I would again
revise the price by 20 30% and would
wait for the secondary report and that's
how you know I keep changing for the
first 2 3 days and keep seeing the
results and once the you know every
keyword gets pick up and I get the you
know starts getting the stable results
then I uh just allow the campaign to
work uh you know on the algorithm and uh
you know I I see uh results actually
moves in the positive direction when you
give some time to campaigns to read and
to learn uh you know from the audience
Behavior Okay so this is about the
keyword planning which we have just seen
now moving to again a very important
aspect because campaign making is
something which I've already given you
the you know Glimpse in the last class
so I would again give you today but
before that I really you know wanted
today to speak on all these technical
aspects you know which works at the back
end so that's why my focus is more on
this uh presentation parallely I would
keep showing you the uh you know uh the
uh Google ads uh the demo and everything
okay so now when we move to the next
part next part is very important from
the um ad algorithm point of view so
what happenss or what used to happen uh
when when the quality score you know
which I'm just trying to speak now was
not there uh what used to happen the one
who used to pay the highest bid price
used to get the first position and the
second one used to get the second
position and the third bidder used to
get the third position so I have just
brought into this table suppose a
Advertiser has bided 8 rupe B 10 C 15
and D 20 and when the quality score
concept was not there so they actually
been given the very direct position this
one first this one second this one third
and this one fourth but they have
realized or Google has realized that the
one who is paying the most is not having
a very good quality of the ad uh his uh
landing page or the website it's is not
working or probably the pages which is
which are connected are not very
relevant
and the keywords on which the ads been
shown is nowhere near uh you know when
the landing page is opened so it it was
like a very negative impact on Google
when the reviews been checked and people
or the users who were clicking on those
ads were not happy so what Google did
Google brought us you know kind of um uh
test score or a check uh which is called
qualy score for every keyword we bid
okay and this is only for the search ads
that's why I said all the keyword weid
okay I'll just show you the result on a
client site so when we submit our ad on
the basis of you know different keyword
we buid and the and the strategy we use
and the landing page we connected the
back end so what the system does is
system starts analyzing and starts
checking everything from top till you
know bottom from the start till the end
and I would just talk about the factors
and what impact it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then
been given to every Advertiser on the
basis of the keyword suppose every
Advertiser here is bidding on the same
keyword you know let's let's um assume
that they all are running the ad for the
digital marketing course so what would
happen they would check and on the basis
of the you know factors they would give
a score out of 10 suppose the a
Advertiser who bid it for the least had
the best of the quality score because of
the reasons we're just going to talk
about B got 8 out of 10 4 out of 10 and
two out of 10 so the one who have bided
the most got the very least quality
score probably the reasons you know
would be more clear once we talk so how
this now we're going to impact the whole
position system is that their Google
rank not Google position okay there is a
Google rank kind of uh kPa can be
understood or a metrix which is um a
product or a multiplication of what you
bid and how much quality score you were
able to get so 8 into 9 brings 72 10
into 8 brings 80 15 into 4 brings 60 and
202 is 40 okay so the combination of a
good pricing and a good quality score
got B bidder as a first position okay
and the one who got the best quality
score but still paying very less from
the average pricing probably is you know
brought the Google position or adart
position to Second and then the one who
was spraying very high but the quality
score was below average which is of
course 56 is average price average score
they've got into third position and the
one who was paying so high probably
would not get a position because this is
the maths from the maths point of view
I've got these numbers if the quality
score would have been below five then
the ad would not have got any position
rather because Google always tries to
you know show the ads which are the best
uh for the users you know because Google
always pays very importance to the users
behavior and users um uh you know
expectations so and when I said that I
think you would able to understand more
now how the factors you know which which
actually results in these quality score
is um like relevance score like by
relevance score means when you type A
quiry or a person would come here would
type A quiry so he doesn't know that
this is called a keyword we as our
digital marketers know this is called a
keyword for them it is a normal query
because they are about to start a course
where they would be taught about all
these things but right now to they are
not very aware you know very much aware
of these things so they are putting a
query when they put a query they want to
see the add or add extensions or add
description relevant to what they have
searched and when they see all these
three things here with the search uh you
know what they made they would
definitely going to click more and
Google only earns when somebody clicks
so it means Google making Revenue only
when somebody's clicking so from that
perspective also Google always tries to
pay you know uh or rather give more
score and give a better position to the
ads where all the components of the ads
are perfect are relevant and the ones
who starts getting more clicks in the
very first hour or a first day okay so
the important factor which after the
click is the landing page so when
somebody opens this so it has to be very
relevant to the query and to whatever
being shown outside they cannot just
show anything here uh which is not
relevant to the ad which has actually
been shown outside so all these you know
uh factors uh in combination gives the
quality score very important factor is
CTR which you must have understood when
you know we uh I I did you know explain
the last session the basic one but if
you do not aware of it so CTR is called
click through rate okay and a click-
through rate is a ratio of clicks to
impression okay it is a ratio of clicks
to
impression just
spell check okay so suppose
today uh when we are saying ABCD so
let's see this this is a or this is B
and this is C and they've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay their
landing page their uh ad their
description everything is very much
common so Google in the starting of the
day you know when the ad actually
started to show for everyone uh you know
given them a very good quality score
probably of five okay okay and when this
qualty score of five been given to them
then the other factor which actually
adds on you know to that algorithm is
the CTR so CTR is I just told you is the
ratio between click to impression so now
they all have a same quality score but
this got 100 clicks out of the th000
Impressions been given today this got 50
clicks out of the th000 Impressions
given today this got by any mean
probably 200 clicks out of the th000
impression is given today okay every
time this this search is happening here
digital marketing course so these three
ads are very much visible equally so all
got th000 Impressions th000 Impressions
th000 Impressions but this got 100
clicks this got 50 clicks and this got
200 Clicks in the very first hour or
maybe in the next two hours okay so this
CTR you know when we are talking about
100 out of th000 to 10% This Is 50 out
of th000 it means this is going to be 5%
and 20 uh sorry 200 out of th000 means
20% of the CTR so Google was actually
benefited or made the most of the
revenue when know clicks have come from
here because it is almost like a double
or a four times of this so because of
the high CTR the quality score of of
course you know every every Advertiser
would improve but this one would be
improved from probably from 5 to 7 and
this would you know probably from 5 to
5.5 and this probably from 5 to six so
because of that quality score has
improved and uh you know because of the
high CTR this had has has got so this
position will be changed and this would
know probably would get the first
position the second position and at the
end of a day this ad has to pay or
Advertiser has to pay lesser because its
quality score increase we have just seen
it is you know almost like the uh you
know inversely proportional the ones who
are actually paying or the ones who are
having the best of the quality score are
paying the least or has to pay the least
okay so this is all basically you know
can be checked once your ad starts
running so I would just open the
client's account uh where you can just
see this
with uh you know bit
better understanding you would able to
get out of
this hopefully I able to show you from
okay I'll just see because I have
multiple advertisers you know but I
cannot just show for all so let me just
check if I can show you from any of the
older
one just wait it is actually asking me
some verification
it's taking too much
time yeah it's it's done now
okay so once this is
done so I will just take you to one of
the accounts where my main focus would
be to just show you how the quality
score report look like and then you know
you would would get a fair idea about
all the factors you have to be focusing
to bring your qualty score high or to
take your qualty score high
okay so I'm just going to open the
search ads because we're talking about a
search ad here only and suppose if I
just go into this uh Campaign which is
of course you know not running right now
but I just want to show you how to check
the report and all suppose this is the
campaign you have run for and you got 75
clicks at a you know um average CPC
price of 40 PESA and you have just given
this much pricing and I have waed for
many keywords but I want to see which
keyword had got the best of the quality
score and how the quality score been
given and all okay so once you reach to
the keyword report here you know at this
level then you see um uh you know uh the
kpis or metrics here which gives the
quality score out of 10 okay you can see
here very well and every key would being
give another you know if if there are 10
keywords I don't know how many keywords
we bided for we bided 50 keywords okay
and and um you know you can see all the
keywords here and every keyword been
given the quality score out of 10 okay
because there CTR which was the last
part which I've explained you the ratio
between the impression two clicks got
the above average so they give uh below
average average and above average so
above average is best actually for any
of the factors so the CTR is above
average the landing page is above
average and their add is above average
means all are perfect then they got the
10 the moment Anything Goes below
average or probably to the average
suppose you can see this is above
average for them this is above average
for them but their landing page
experience from this keyword point of
view is only average their quality score
has come to eight okay if you go further
down uh let's see anything where two of
them uh yeah so here the kids ride on is
a keyword where CTR is also not as high
or as great you know to as compared to
the other keyword which we we have seen
and also the landing page is not as
relevant to the keyword so there uh two
factors like CTR and landing page has
come to average as compared to the ad
relevance which is above average so
their whole quality score got impacted
which actually came down from 10 to 8
and then 7 for this particular keyword
and last not least if I just take you to
somewhere where something is below
average has come now one is above
average one is okay they are getting
clicks but probably the ad is still not
very much relevant to the keyword okay
so they are below average above average
average has brought the quality score to
6 out of 10 which certainly would have
you know impacted on the cost and also
to the position okay so this is
something which you would see when you
come here also you can check one more
thing here suppose you have bided for
your keyword and your bid price where
you are paying for is maximum bid price
let me just see where that column is
so otherwise I would just add that
column so that you can learn that part
as
well
[Music]
okay just wait okay so this is
basically CPC price is being given in
the average cost 2.50 is the cost for
every click and we got 249 clicks so got
623 you can just check the mats
it's always good to cross check so 249
clicks multiplied by the CPC price which
is 2.50 rupe would give you 6 22.5 which
is the cost you know for the keywords um
you know we bed for and the total clicks
we have paid okay and the maximum bid
price suppose you know you have got uh
the maximum bid price of uh 1 rupe and
you paid 17 PESA 1.66 and all and then
what happens you want to secure your
position suppose the very first page bid
you seeing that you're getting the
position but you're not getting on a
first page then here because this
campaign is not running so I'm just
giving you the hypothetical example so
whatever the pricing you would have
given for the particular keyword suppose
we talk about these three keywords right
now or particular one keyword I suppose
so this is something which I'm know
trying to show on a one rupe cost but to
show on the first page it is is saying
that you have to pay 1.5 okay to show on
the uh first four positions here 1 2 34
it is saying that probably you have to
pay 2.5 and to get the absolute first
position which is going to be the
topmost it would tell you that you have
to probably pay 5 rupe you know you're
paying one it is asking 1.5 the first
four it can be paid for 2.53 or this has
to be five so you can always go and and
change your you know bid price for the
particular keyword okay so there are
ways to do it suppose if I'll just go
here and I just go to the edit I can
change my maximum CPC bid price for this
particular bid or keyword like to 5 rup
okay because I'm not changing for all
the keywords so I have selected that
particular keyword and I have made the
change to this particular keyword to 5
rupe so if you know the average price
was one and I was not getting the
keyword uh from this keyword the
position secured on the first page or
first absolute position and I want
because this is the most important
keyword for me then I would just come
here and would check the pricing okay
this says 5 rupees you have to pay for
the top position so I will just go here
edit and would change the bid price or a
maximum CPC bid price of this particular
keyword you can do for all you know you
have to just of course you know select
all of course but if you would do for
all then it it can really impact your
whole budget
okay so try to go for the keywords where
you really feel like it is required and
always go by the quality score it has
you know it has a very good quality
score so I should be paying or I should
be ready in paying uh the maximum price
which actually Google is asking me to
pay to secure are my first absolute
position and certainly that would
increase the chances of clicks and
certainly if clicks are there so
conversion can be expected to okay so
this is all from what I've just taught
you as a now now I will just move to the
campaign making though we have done as I
told you last time but I will try to
make it again so that we can quickly see
how the Google ad search ads or the
search Google ad created okay so if I
just go to the campaign uh My Demo
account so I have just go to the Google
ads account the dashboard and then I
would come to the
campaigns I will just click
Plus new
campaign and whatever the you know um
objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
campaign because we are making the ad
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate uh session all
together so we are not doing the
conversion and remarketing today we
making a normal search ad with all the
strategies we have just understood and
with uh adding the extensions to the ad
as well today okay website visit and
suppose my website is um just open sa
learns uh landing
page so that I can make the ad for
simply addal marketing as a demo ad of
course not a main ad so copying and just
putting in here I have to just put a uh
you know website domain that's it I
don't have to bring the whole landing
page here and then I can just name it
probably
November search
add and then I would just go and
continue start
new and then I'll just select my bidding
strategy which is going to be clicks and
of course from my Excel I would learn
that okay my bid price which I'm going
to be paying uh you know uh is certainly
in the range of something like probably
50 60 and I have just told you that I
bring my price kind of a thing into this
like I always bring like this and then
let me just delete all the other column
which are not
required so this is the sheet which are
explained you earlier with the index
value and all so my price what is my
price like so I always pay 30% 40% extra
to the lit price so I can you know just
get the formula here like
this
plus this
30% okay so that is just going to make
it 57 so you can just understand 44 + 13
going to bring 57 and I can just drag it
and now I've got the average suppose
these are the you know keywords which I
have finalized just assuming so these
are the keywords which I have finalized
probably because of XYZ factors search
as an index value and all that and I see
that my pricing is varying from 35 to 89
so maximum paying 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head I would going to
give the limit to my bid price that I
don't want to pay anything extra or more
than 90 okay so this is something which
you can do on this this particular level
and then you move ahead and you remove
this because you just want to keep your
ad on the Google search and then you go
down you select your countries you
select your location if you want to show
the ad in all the locations then you
certainly can just go uh and keep the
very first option open which is uh all
countries and territories if you want to
just show your ad um uh in a particular
country like you know right now if I
just go India so the whole India would
see your ad and if you want to go for a
manual locations like suppose I want to
select any of the states or cities then
what I would do I would just probably
take Delhi so Delhi would be targeted
like this okay or probably I just want
to Target the state of Texas here so I
just would go and Target the whole state
or if I want to Target any of the
provinces of Canada so I would just go
go and take the uh provinces of Ontario
Canada and I would just Target the whole
Province and now if I also want to go
for any of the uh PIN codes suppose I
want to Target to a certain pin code
then I can just go and Target the PIN
codes like this so it is up to us that
we want to go worldwide or if you want
to go for a country specific if you want
to go for a state specific or if you
want to grow as a province or a pin code
specific okay otherwise uh if you
suppose um a restaurant or if you are a
you know somebody who only delivers into
certain radius then you can just leave
all these options and you can go and
advance search and then you can go into
radius and you can just bring this uh
whatever you understand better in India
we understand kilometers better maybe
the person in us would understand miles
better so we just go and take that 2 km
radius and probably I am the cake shop
in Delhi so I was just going to search
my location this is my location and I
was just going to Target people around 2
km because I don't deliver outside 2 km
so it's all up to us how we want to go
uh this is called radius targeting or
Geo fencing when we go to the location
we can also learn one thing suppose I
want to show the ad to the um whole
country India I've targeted but at the
same time I I am not delivering in um uh
in in in Mumbai okay or probably in uh
Karnataka you know bangaluru where the
city is okay probably I'm not delivering
in any of the uh northern states like
harana Himachal Punjab so what I would
do I would just take Punjab suppose for
example and I'm just going to exclude
that okay so what would happen now my ad
would show in all the states and all the
cities of India but just not in Punjab
okay so I can save it that's how you go
about the location language is you know
in which language the users probably
uses the search engine and all so you
can keep it all languages that's the
best and audience we don't cater here
much because we are doing the search ad
which actually shows the ad on the basis
of keywords and location only so in the
display ad we're going to talk about
this uh one and that would be the next
video I would create so we're going to
learn a lot of things from the audience
segment in the next display and
and then the more settings comes where
you talk about the ad rotation so ad
rotation is already default being
selected as the perform best ad uh if uh
because the nowadays the ad actually
been created uh responsive and dynamic
so when we'll reach to the ad level I'll
show you uh the headline changes for
every user the description sometime
changes for the user what I mean is if
such is selecting or you know writing
this keyword so probably this headline
is shown to me and after 1 hour if I
come again and would search the same
term so the headline from the same
Advertiser could be different or the
description could be different so that's
how the dynamic ADS works like okay so
once you are done with this okay the
start and dat is important you know the
basics from the previous chapter so I'm
just going a bit faster in here so you
would select the date and then if you
want to schedule this campaign for a
certain period like suppose you don't
want to run on the weekends so you can
just select Monday to Fridays and you
know our time whichever suits you
suppose just like a very common time of
8:00 a.m. to uh you know the late nights
like 23:45 and you don't want to run the
weekends if you want um Saturday Sunday
to be you know 24 hours then you don't
have to put any timing so that goes like
24 hours for Saturday Sundays and then
you click next and you reach to the next
level where it will just going to ask
you for certain things like keywords you
want to submit and the ad you want to
run for and the add copy you know you
have to create okay so once you come
here it uh is the you know work you have
done so you can just copy paste them and
you know bring in there uh and otherwise
these all keywords are the ones which
Google has suggested you from you know
the page which you have submitted okay
so the landing page is this so I'll try
to change the landing page first so that
I can get more appropriate keywords and
then it would going to search again or
scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of we can always click on
and now the keywords would be more
digital marketing oriented because this
landing page will be scanned by Google
and this would show us certain results
which would of course going to be
digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
we don't know uh what is the pricing of
these keywords is what is the
competition of these keywords is how
much the monthly search has been so we
go by our own maths we we calculate we
do all this pre- homework on the Keyword
Planner sheet just like we did today and
and then we bring them here by deleting
all what they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then we ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
being used how the copy is created I'll
just show uh you some you know strategic
part of it ensure that your landing page
is correct and it is opening there you
know otherwise your ad would not be
approved secondly always give a display
path display path is something which is
added after the ad or the landing page
link suppose I'm selling
online digital marketing so I would just
going to write whatever I want to
show probably I'll just keep it
here
marting okay so that works okay so now
it has come digital marketing and then
the part comes where you know you have
to
be I'll just going to tell you the call
extension once the art is created so
headlines and all so the headline is
something which
shows you know you know the basics so
I'll be fast again under the landing
page link this blue which actually uh
you know brings the most of the
engagement or which actually appeals the
user to click it is something in blue
which is you know going to the headline
so we have to be focusing very much on
bringing the best of the headlines here
so that we can get the best of the
clicks because you know once the click
increases the CTR increases CTR
increases the quality score would
increase quality score would increase
your costing would come down and your
position would rise so you have to
ensure that your headlines your clicks
everything is in you know in a line
whatever we have learned so your
headlines right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing
okay and I'm just going to get the
headlines as a suggestion being given
okay and um we can have more ideas from
here by clicking this so they are not
giving any so we can always have from
the keywords which we have submitted so
probably digital marketing course
online try to get your best keywords
here this is okay this is nice this can
be
changed
digital marketing
course online is not taking so this
Marketing Online probably I'll just take
because course are already submitted and
then I can take few more like social
media marketing I just
seen whatever the length it would accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the
rest this is the one and I should ensure
that I I have at least 10 headlines or
12 headlines so six been given and
headline section actually you know been
given like a half blue and then I would
see headlines which are unique so unique
you should have a uh you know online
availability benefits and the offers and
all or call to action so
enroll
register
today for free demo
then we'll talk
about you can see the moment I've added
the headline the strength has changed
100 uh
plus tools for
free
job
assistance
program okay so I'm just adding few
random things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen uh these headlines in any of
the atank companies ads uh include some
popular keywords popular keywords could
be your brand name as well so
simply
learn
courses
online hopefully the spelling is fine
and
um
weekend bat
for
professionals
uhoh just a batch for
professionals and that's it you know
because I already added a lot of
keywords lot of headlines probably 11 so
I just not work on the headlines anymore
uh and I'll see you know if description
doesn't takes it high then I'll I'll
just add one more but right now the
description is also not giving me the
full uh tick like in the headline unique
and the headlines been given so I'll
just try to bring the description so
simply in online online that's great
that's great I just try to get something
from Google itself let's see what they
have given so I'll just going to bring
this one okay so that it is been taken
from the landing page itself so that
would make a difference
to uh the quality score simple digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to
put our courses focus on
skills see to
do focus
on El like seu PC
analytics just to this one here so that
has been picked up so now you can see
this is also been picked up and the last
thing I would do is now going to bring
some headline again you know I'll just
check probably uh digital marketing
certification I'm not sure if this
headline I have submitted earlier or not
but I'm just going to test it out okay
so
cation
training so now it has you know come
down to good and uh that's the best you
know right now we can do of course uh
you can take it further but yeah that
doesn't um uh matter if you are just
stuffing it to get this one completed
you have to just ensure that all the
keywords or all the headlines are
relevant just do not overdo 10 to 12 are
okay okay once this is done your ad is
created you can just click done and and
you can click
next and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we'll just take you back so
because you know that your average CPC
price would be around 80 you know
whatever the pricing you have just got
from here if you know the sheet and I
was explaining you so the the the bid
price which you have submitted for you
know when I told you is like something
which is in this range uh 80 90 whatever
it is so you know that bit price would
come down to 90 and you need um at least
100 clicks today so 90 into 100 going to
be your 9,000 daily budget so because
you know that you know you would end up
in paying maximum 90 rupees per click
because that's the maximum bid price you
have submitted if that comes down to 70
80 60 then of course your clicks would
increase but right now to being very uh
you know hypothe hypothetically thinking
that okay I would pay 90 rupees per
click at Max because that is what I
submitted so to get 100 clicks I have to
pay 90 into 100 it would be 9,000 your
you know daily budget has to be so you
would come here and you would just going
to change it set a custom budget and you
would going to bring down 9,000 rupees
here okay so on that aage CPC whatever
it would be you would get the number of
clicks if you have CPC goes down from 90
to 45 then of course you are not going
to get only 100 you rather get double
amount which is going to be 200 okay
when that is done then you just click
next and your budget goes you know your
campaign goes for a review
and then you can add the extensions from
outside okay so they're just giving you
some of the uh you know kind of uh
suggestions so let's see uh there is one
issue in the
ad let me just check that
first let me just
see can always fix
it but that would again you're not going
to give you the option of um publishing
you know till you fix it but it is not
clickable I don't
know uh what is the
problem I just go if from here sometimes
those links doesn't work so let's see
what is
issue one contains
and okay so we just to do that
the character limit part I have not
given the space so that is something
which is not acceptable by them just
going to put like skills like this
and now so these all small things you
know they
do take uh care of so here only because
we have come down so why not just to see
the extension here itself because that
would uh going to save our efforts by
going from outside so when you see the
ad you see some EXT extensions here like
you know when you have created the ad
right now so you have created only till
this limit okay this is the elements you
have put it up right now the landing
page the headlines the description but
in this ad by emerus you can see more
links like apply to IMS learn how
industry so one is landing page and
three different uh Pages or sub pages
also been shown in this same ad how they
are done so they are done through the
extension called site link okay so you
can see here if you go down after the
headline there's an option to have the
site links here okay so you can just
click plus here itself I'm not
submitting the ad because I wanted just
to show you from here itself and then
you can go down because in your case
these would not be given because mine
are already created yours are not so you
would go down and you would create the
new new site link from here and you can
just give a name suppose
download
brocher and then you can give URL of
that download brocher page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page like this like
this has to be the landing page which is
workable for the downloading brocher of
course so this would be added and then I
can just go and probably add um uh
testy
monals and
reviews okay so somebody wants to read
the uh you know um testimon and reviews
of when when they see the ad so you can
see that on the desktop how that would
look like so they would have an ad and
then they would have these four links
and all which you have just seen in the
Google when I shown you so final URL of
reviews can be given which would
directly take them to the page where the
reviews been given and uh site two could
be anything you know which you can just
see um industry ready modules or the fee
structure you know the fee structure is
something which people always always
wants to just
know from the uh very first glimpse of
the art itself so I can just
BBE take them to the page where fee is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh maybe
tools
provided now tools
and
certificates you would get so that can
also be one of the links which people
would very much interested in you know
clicking and checking okay so you would
see the the ad in certain shape you
would have a normal headline uh the
description which you have put it up and
then four links where people can
directly reach okay and then you know
this had to be saved here and you can
always see the preview which I've
already shown you but yeah this is how
that would look like so you are add your
add and your four uh extra links which
actually be added okay so this is one
which you can apply
now and now your ad has the extensions
in addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your add as uh
the number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here AB right now it
is not showing any of the ads with the
number but they you know uh generally
have advertisers have nowadays the
numbers in addition to the headline and
everything okay so you can add that as
well by just going up and you can see
there is an option of calls okay okay
let me you can add from here uh
certainly I can show you but you know
you can just go down and add the number
by clicking your country and you know
giving your number here it will just be
cross checked by some verification and
all so that is done you can save it so
you can see what actually I was showing
you you know I would just show you um
from outside also that if by any of the
uh you know um that is done that we have
corrected so you don't have to be you
know uh worried about if I just click
done so that should not be there if it
is still there I have to check now which
spacing it is actually talking about um
actually I have unacceptable spacing
contains comma I think I have just
corrected it but it is not taking maybe
I have to just U um delete the whole
description probably that would
something which I would save our
time okay so we not adding that
description
though done so this is actually you know
kind of a bug because that is something
which has been deleted rather in front
of you so this is not
um taking but I would just click next
and probably this would now be not the
error in which we would see so you go
for a review so what I was saying I did
shown you from outside the you know the
the campaign was created from the ad
itself how the S site link is connected
and how the uh call being added for now
the publish campaign you can see because
that add error actually been rectified
so if by mistake you know you just
forgotten that you have to add the call
number or extension you know which we
just added so what you don't have to be
worried because once you back to the
dashboard you know where you would see
all your campaigns certainly you would
see your this campaign as well in which
you have just created then you can just
go inside the
um add group and then you can see there
is ADD and assets let me just click
that so there is an ad which you just
created and there's an assets you know
where you could see uh
the extensions and all like you know you
just have added today and we just added
this site link and this number so if I
want to add again or if I would have
forgotten then what I can do I can just
go and take from here suppose if uh that
call extension was not added there you
know when I just added you would come
here in the assets you would click that
plus button and then you would just go
to the call and you would see the same
kind of a preview which you have seen
inside the ad when we were creating okay
nothing different it just like the you
know way you do it you know either you
do when the ad was created or otherwise
you can just go uh let the campaign be
created published and you can come from
outside you can click the add in assets
you can go to plus and you can create
any of these uh extensions we'll talk
about more in the coming you know
tutorials and demos uh and the sessions
but today you know we'll wind up here I
just uh you know wanted to give you the
thorough uh learning on the Google
search chart with the extensions and
also the main uh agenda for today was to
make you understand how these these you
know terms works like and how the
keywords can be researched how you can
bring your own pricing to the keywords
how you can save the cost and of course
to understand how the quality score
works like you can have lot of videos on
a YouTube where you can find the quality
score of Google ads working though I
tried to you know bring everything under
this session but still if you want to go
for a deep learning you can always
search more and research more if you are
an aspiring digital marketer then have a
look at simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing 2 years of
experience is preferred so hurry up and
enroll Now find the cost Link in the
description box social media marketing
actually means what is it yeah and we
got to put this in the context of the
definition of
marketing yeah I studied Marketing in
the very early days in the 80s and um my
main sort of uh Guru in marketing was
Philip Cotler and and over the years
marketing has sort of developed from
traditional marketing to online
marketing but the basic concept has not
changed if you look at the definition of
marketing it's the activity of creating
communicating delivering and exchanging
offerings that have value for
customers yeah so you supply you deliver
deliver you exchange products or
services that have a value for your
customers so two very important aspects
here there is value and there is
customer and that is what we capture in
the marketing concept you put the
customer at the core of what you do yeah
because when you do that you
automatically will look at what value
are we giving to the
customer yep so take social media
marketing in that context then the
second part of the social media
marketing sort of term is the word
social media what is social media when I
explain social media I'm using the three
C's the three C's of social media
marketing and they are content they're
community and campaigns
content is the fuel of your social media
content is the um the currency of social
media if you have really good content
that you can share on the
internet yeah using various multip
multiple social media channels like
Facebook like YouTube or like video or
like Instagram or blogging you name it
yeah people will engage with your
content and then when people start
engaging with your content they may come
back for more content that you supply
and they will then become part of your
community so Community is a very
important aspect of your social media
definition with really good content you
can create community
and then you can push that process by
running
campaigns yeah and a campaign makes it
relevant for
businesses because when you run a
campaign you have a goal for your
campaign you have an objective you have
a start date you have an end
date yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns to develop your communities
with really exciting
content and then you put it into the
marketing context you do that with a
customer at in the core of what you
do yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media
marketing is very basic it says the use
of social media to develop a company's
brand increase website traffic and boost
sales that is what we call social media
marketing yeah the most important aspect
here is that you need to have an outcome
you need to have a result which is
customer
related and that is where the sales
element comes in you do this to get the
customer to do something and in the end
that is buying your product or your
service yeah so social media marketing
is not the
Tactical combination of your social
media networks yeah to um to reach as
many people there needs to be a goal to
it and when we talk about marketing it
comes down to selling your product or
service with a
value yeah so that is the um kind of the
call to action as it were that comes out
of your social media marketing so keep
that in mind everything you do with your
social media marketing in the end comes
down to reaching your goals or achieving
your objectives of developing your
company's brand increasing website
traffic or growing your
sales now a big benefit that you're
getting these days in digital marketing
and social media marketing is
data is
intelligence is
knowledge in the early days of marketing
the biggest problem has always being how
to measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness if I
do a PR campaign and uh they write about
me in the newspaper how do I measure the
effectiveness of that how can I track
that when somebody buys a product it
actually is as a result of the pr
campaign that I Ran So in the early pre-
internet days yeah we the only way to
measure customer engagement as it were
were through Loyalty cards or credit
cards yeah with a loyalty card you had
some basic customer data through credit
cards you could track transactions but
it's very difficult to relate that to
your marketing then the internet emerged
and all of a sudden I could track
traffic to my
website yeah I could see how many people
visit my website are these people that
visit my website for the first time are
they returning visitors what are the
most popular pages that they see how
long do they stay on my website and are
they actually buying my
product yeah so that was a major
advancement of marketing in the early
2000s and then when social media emerged
it all of a sudden became possible to
measure
engagement how many people are having
conversations with us I could even
measure sentiments are people positive
about my brand are they negative about
my brand I I could track the
effectiveness of my marketing
campaigns I could measure the
effectiveness of my advertising
campaigns that I ran online so today's
reality is that we can measure
everything we can measure clicks we can
measure transactions we can measure
engagements we can measure return on
investments yeah and we can now even
take that a step further through
artificial intelligence that we can
actually start making predictions
how people may respond to campaigns that
we're going to be running so it's a very
important aspect of your digital uh your
social media marketing now let's go into
the social media marketing tips and
tricks number one set up your
goals now what good will your actions do
if you don't have a goal in mind the
goal of your marketing strategy may be
the driving force behind every decision
that you make and this is exactly why
setting up goals is very important
moreover your marketing efforts have to
align with the goals of the
organization here are some things that
you need to keep in mind while setting
up your goals first of all your goals
need to be quantitative for example you
need to have a thousand conversions by
the end of the quarter or 5,000
followers on Instagram by the end of the
month and so on number two you need to
stick to a consistent deadline this
gives weight for each of your options
and number three make sure your goals
are smart now smart refers to specific
measurable attainable relevant and
time-based now let's go to number four
like I mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy and alongside these goals there
also needs to be the Northstar metric
now what is the Northstar metric well
this represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this Northstar
metric will also give your team Clarity
and
focus now let's have a look at some
popular northstars there's increased
engagement greater conversion rates more
leads generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two understanding
your audience
social media allows you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
Audience by understanding what they need
want and desire you can deliver content
in a way that makes your product or
service the answer that they're looking
for there are also other ways that you
can understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of
Their audience by conversing with them
in full forums responding to their
comments and blogs and social media
taking up their feedbacks of suggestions
into consideration and acting on them
and so
on now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learn's audience is predominantly
working professionals and graduates
unacademy has high school graduates and
BYU app has as high school students as
users now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform now when performing social
media marketing choosing the right
platform is really
important When selecting them you need
to ask questions like why you're using
that particular platform who you will
reach with this platform what content
could work best on the platform and is
there any content that was unique to
that platform like for example YouTube
and then there's the
video answering these questions will
help you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest now let's talk about the
purpose of each of these platforms
LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences for
Facebook well just about everyone has an
account on
it content that is related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook then we have Instagram visual
content works best on Instagram now
although it works well for static images
and short form video It Doesn't Really
drive a lot of traffic to your website
and then finally we have Pinterest
Pinterest is also limited to to static
images however it's highly effective at
driving traffic to your
blog now let's go to number four setting
up a social media
calendar a social media calendar demands
the message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform let's have a look at some of
the most popular types of posts on
social media first off we have
competitions now I'm sure all of you
have seen posts like tag a friend who
does this or comment or like to win
something and stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social social
media then we have polls and surveys
polls can help you if you need a
collection that also encourages
followers to take action and interact
polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't and to receive their
feedback and then we have videos and
live streams although we'll be covering
this in a little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with video and
live streams goes a long way to drive
engagement among your audience these
will help get your followers attention
increased trust and credibility and have
a high response rate and has so much
more to offer live stream with its live
nature and having a human face alongside
your business humanizes your brand and
by extension helps increase customer
loyalty and trust and then there is
infographics articles and images so
social media calendars are success ful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective
manner next up we have number five using
social media marketing
tools social media marketing tools align
to the goals of your organization with
it you can create highquality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement
and it also helps you with the planning
process you can plan create and schedule
posts on your social
calendar now some of the more popular
social media tools include buffer hoot
site buzzsumo I T and much more now
these tools also help with generating
leads creating email lists finding a
relevant audience to show your content
creating buyer personas providing you
insights on what works and what doesn't
and giving you templates for different
kinds of
posts now for number six visual
storytelling visual storytelling
involves passing out a lot of
information in the simplest of forms
visually using pictures and videos your
followers are able to grasp the message
quickly and remember it for a long time
afterwards visual storytelling is also
not limited by language barriers and
this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
and engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much
more but it also has some other
advantages it helps you build a bond
with your audience visual storytelling
connects with your audience methods like
live streaming help humanize your brand
and help grow customer loyalty and trust
it has the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential
customers so have a look at some of our
videos so here's what is machine
learning data science in 5 minutes and
AI in 5 minutes now these are some of
our most viewed videos on our Channel
and now you know why visual storytelling
if you guys are interested in watching
these videos you can check them out on
our Channel homepage and we also have
similar videos on blockchain devops and
Six Sigma but now back to the
list let's go to number seven paying for
avertising this is a method that helps
you find a Target and and reach your
audience with ease it can greatly help
with achieving your organization's
marketing
goal and this can help you improve your
reach and improve your Brand's
visibility it's payperclick model and
shows cost Effectiveness by providing
great results and return on investment
it also helps improve targeting by
letting you control who sees your ad you
get to choose from a number of different
factors like interest
Hobbies personality types alongside the
basic user demographics like age
location gender and so on now since most
social media platforms have native
analytics you also get to assess and
Define the performance of your ad
campaigns now as great as it sounds
there are certain pitfalls that come
along with peer advertising first of all
your audience could get exposed to your
post too many many times and tune out
your content disregarding it in the
process second it could get really
expensive for small businesses or
startups to manage a campaign to its
maximum Effectiveness third people could
pass off your content as irrelevant or
unimportant and you also have to deal
with a lot of
competition smaller companies with
lesser budgets have more of an uphill
battle to deal with than better funded
organizations
next we have number eight
newsjacking newsjacking is a method that
involves using current events to promote
your own Brands products and services
now it's a popular method that's used to
improve brand awareness newsjacking uses
the popularity of current events and
drives it to your brand it helps shine a
spotlight on your products and it also
helps you show off that you are up
to-date with current events in the
industry as and that your product is
relevant by extension it also improves
engagement and website
traffic now for number nine AB
testing AB testing is a popular method
for comparing copies creatives and ctas
or call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content AB testing helps determine which
of the variants your audience engaged
with the
most AB testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on and next up number 10 community and
influences joining communities helps
your brand link up with like-minded
people and other companies belonging to
your Niche it'll also help you establish
your brand as an authority within the
industry actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up
with and on the other hand partnering up
with influencers helps promote your
products or services to a brand new
audience it helps provide an additional
layer of authenticity in YouTube which
is also a social media platform if you
didn't know here's some very very
popular influencers we have Marcus
brownley unbox therapy Mr who's the boss
and lonus Tech tips each of them with
more than 4 million
subscribers and finally we're at number
11 measuring and analyzing
results accurately tracking and
measuring your marketing efforts are an
important part of the process it ensures
that you're making the most out of your
campaigns now it's really important that
you find key metrics that are crucial
for your brand and these metrics can be
tracked weekly monthly or on a quarterly
basis and based on these results
appropriate actions can be
taken so on Facebook you could look out
for reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for Impressions clicks
and Impressions and interactions on
LinkedIn and likes comments and mentions
on Instagram and engagements and
Impressions on
Pinterest some of the most popular tools
used for this purpose are Sprout social
buffer HootSuite Google analytics and so
on is literally content marketing um
okay what is it so content marketing Is
Not A New Concept it's been around for
over a hundred years in fact one of the
classic Foundation stories of you know
the birth of content marketing goes all
the way back to to the Michelin Brothers
in France and the Michelin Brothers you
know in case you haven't done your
history that's okay you know little
refresher right now were two brothers
who made pneumatic tires and they were
trying to sell them along with an
Innovative product at its time called
the
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my God what was worth going out
there for you know rep Paris it's all
happening here and what the Michelin
Brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more
tires they had to get people to drive
farther and farther and use them so what
did they come up with the concept that
really is the birth of content Marketing
in my
book was the Michelin guide and the
Michelin guide was unique in that it
reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to die for the Ratatouille H you
you got to have it this is a three- Star
Restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way and since we're
going to give you a guide and you have
to get out of Paris in order to get
there we're going to tell you where you
can find gasoline along the way uh which
hotels uh you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a Pneumatic and you know
what it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or a tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to Their audience about
what Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in
1900 was
food and by creating
content but got the audience to get into
their new Innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there into the provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three- Star
Restaurant people got more Flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the
way Michelin solds more tires so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of you know hit a pause and like well
we're doing content marketing and we
need to come up with a concept think
back to the Michelin guide it's it's a
great
foundation so let's go to a modern
definition where are we now in the 21st
century when it comes to content
marketing well you can read the slide
here and read the definition and some
people like reading definitions I'm not
going to read it to you but I am going
to highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are
absolutely critical to any
definition of content
marketing the content that you create
needs to be
relevant and it also has to be
valuable now if it's not relevant then
you're not actually meeting my needs or
interests you know and why would I be
interested in and we've gotten way too
tired of screening out the commercial
comes on um you know trying to sell us
snow tires and pardon me we live in
Florida I don't use snow tires what what
the heck is this commercial doing you
know interrupting what I'm
watching so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out and the
valuable the valuable can can work in a
lot of different ways it could be
interesting it can be useful you know
value is an interesting proposition all
by
itself but that's the key to content
marketing uh it's not just creating more
spam it's not just throwing more trash
over the fence and hoping something
happens this is something where if
you've created valuable and relevant
content you know what your customers
will find you it's a whole different
kind of
proposition I know there's some Skeptics
are saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module
three but let me just be clear
here social media content is part of
what content marketing needs to create
but it can also create content for your
website and that's not the social media
it can also create content that U your
PR people can and share with uh uh
reporters or bloggers and that's not
normally considered uh social media
content and by the way all of that
content can be optimized so maybe it
actually is part of SEO not social media
marketing in fact that's the other place
that content marketing really
overlaps and it's not
coincidental it so happens that around
February
2011 when Google rolled out the first of
its multiple versions of the panda
update all of a sudden even seos started
to pay attention to content marketing
why because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant you
know what it's not going to rank very
well in our search
algorithm and all of a sudden people who
had been used to like putting keywords
in the right places realized content
matters you mean I've got to actually
tell stories that are interesting I've
got to create information that's
valuable yeah yeah you can make it
relevant that's the optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash God bless you good luck so yeah
content marketing has grown it's like
tripled in terms of web search interest
some
the panda update and we're talking about
Panda 1 of course there was Panda 2
Panda 3 Panda 4 I mean come on Google is
driving us in this direction and so
content marketing is pretty relevant
today now one of the other things that
uh people in content marketing struggle
with is oh but you don't understand I do
B2B content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right well possibly maybe on
occasion so let's just question that
assumption for a
second you know content marketing has
been around now long enough and enough
people have done it but some research
has been conducted and it's been
conducted against B Toc marketers and
B2B marketers and small business
marketers and Enterprise level
marketers and when they start asking key
questions like like okay we're going to
try to determine what is the difference
between an effective content marketer
and an ineffective content
marketer let's see the results well
first of all the most important thing to
Be an Effective BC content
marketer is you need a documented
content
strategy oh okay all right mean people
who are winging it aren't as uh
effective as people who actually have
thought about this and written it down
got it okay no great Insight but you
know interesting to note secondly they
got to have somebody in charge who
oversees content marketing oh Lord does
that mean we have to have a reorg or
maybe we just have to designate somebody
who reports to somebody else whatever
but guess what it really helps if
somebody is driving this process
third they've got to be using more
content marketing tactics than their
less effective
peers and this is not an argument more
is better this is just pardon me that's
the way the data falls out the people
who are actually more effective are
doing more different kinds of
things a broader range of
tactics and who knows maybe it's that
broader range that's part of the success
formula same thing is true with social
media
platforms the effective content
marketers are using more than the
ineective ones and last but not least
and this may be a sort of a result of
the first four by gosh effective content
marketers generally have greater
percentage of the overall marketing
budget in their
organization wow okay that's the BTC
marketing for but you don't understand
I'm not a b2c
marketer okay so let's take a look at
the B2B content marketing
formula guess what you need to have a
documented content marketing strategy to
Be an Effective B2B content marketer you
need to have someone who oversees
content marketing strategy it helps if
you are using more tactics and more
social media platforms and guess what
you spend a higher percentage of your
overall marketing Budget on content
marketing well that's similar to the B
Toc content markets but you understand
B2B is different yeah there's a couple
small differences but guess what overall
the top five criteria are similar and
when you get to small business here's
what you're going to see same five
criteria and you're in an Enterprise I
know the world is different for
Enterprises actually not so much so four
different data points let's net it out
there's a pattern and the pattern is is
I don't care what flavor of content
marketer you are you can be B Toc B2B
you can be small business you can be
large Enterprise at the end of the day
there are five things that you've got to
focus on if you want to be
effective we've already covered these
and are there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
BB and B Toc well
sure but they're all at the
margin what's the downside if we don't
do this you know is anyone going to come
in and like whack us and the answer is
um maybe not inside your boardroom but
it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your salespeople makes they
may encounter someone I like to call the
man in the chair and the Man in the
chair actually refers back to a classic
McGraw Hill ad campaign from I think the
1960s but basically the guy in the chair
asks theoretically some questions from
quote maybe your salesperson okay I
don't know anything about you I don't
know about your company I don't know
about your company's product I don't
know about your company's you know
reputation or anything about you and so
what was it you were going to try to
sell me and that's the downside of not
not having a Content marketing
program content marketing has been
around for over a 100 years but in the
online World customers are behaving in
lots of new ways and they're consuming
content on various kinds and types of
devices that changes things content
marketing is now about creating content
that consumers will engage with and act
upon not just read read or listen to or
watch so in this introductory module
we're going to provide you with an
understanding of how content marketing
affects the decisionmaking process when
people are on the customer journey to
making a purchase and with a solid
content marketing strategy your
customers buying decisions can actually
uh happen faster you can basically uh
shorten the decision your making process
and you can reach and expand um to new
prospects so one of the things that we
hope that you're going to uh learn after
uh basically taking this module uh you
should be able to do the following first
of all you can Define content marketing
and other related Concepts secondly you
should be able to explain why content
needs to be relevant and valuable and in
order for it to be effective third you
need to describe uh the overlap between
content marketing SEO social media
marketing fourth you need to name five
traits of effective content
marketers and last but not least you
need to explain the benefits of content
marketing these are our objectives and
hopefully they're going to be your
learning outcomes so content marketing
Is Not A New Concept it's been around
for over a hundred years in fact one of
the classic Foundation stories of you
know the birth of content marketing goes
all the way back to the Michelin
Brothers in France and the Michelin
Brothers you know in case you haven't
done your history that's okay you know
little refresher right now were two
brothers who made pneumatic tires and
they were trying to sell them along with
an Innovative product at its time called
the a
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my God what was worth going out
there for you know rep Paris it's all
happening here and what the Michelin
Brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more
tires they had to get people to drive
farther and farther and use them
so what did they come up with the
concept that really is the birth of
content Marketing in my
book was the Michelin
guide and the Michelin guide was unique
in that it reviewed
restaurants not just restaurants nearby
in Paris but restaurants out there in
the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to die for the Ratatouille oh you
you got to have it this is a three- Star
Restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way uh which hotels
uh you might want to stay at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a Pneumatic and you know
what it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or uh tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to Their audience about
what Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in
1900 was
food and by creating
content that got the audience to get
into their new Innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there into the provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three star
restaurant people got more Flats
people had to replace their tires but it
was worth it and oh by the
way Michelin solds more tires so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of you know what is email marketing well
email has been around for a very long
time of course and in the very early
days there wasn't an email marketing
service that you could use yeah you
couldn't easily send out hundred of
emails so what you did you were actually
using the BCC or the blind carbon copy
in your email system to send out emails
to many people of course the IT
department of companies in those early
days they didn't like that because it
would block the email system of the
company so they come up with little
marketing uh email Marketing Solutions
on the company's main frame but it was
all very inflexible you had to take your
email you had to take your mailing list
give that to the guy in the IT
department and if you're lucky then
maybe in a couple of days later your
email would be sent you wouldn't get any
data at all about those emails yeah you
knew how many emails were sent but you
didn't know who would have opened the
email or who would have clicked on the
email nowadays of course things are
completely different yeah now you have
email marketing where you can use email
service providers who offer you you lots
of tools and lots of analytics to manage
and plan and measure your email
marketing campaigns so what actually is
email marketing it uses email addresses
from people to inform your email list
about your product or service we call
these commercial emails which is
completely different of course from the
billions of personal emails that are
being sent
yeah around the uh the internet every
day so this is a commercial email that
you send to an email list about your
product your service or a newsletter and
what have you Additionally you can
integrate it into your marketing
automation so you can and it can help
your customers to see your latest
products and offers and you can
obviously use the email list to and
persuade them to buy or book a demo or
sign up for a trial or register for an
event yeah we call this email nurturing
where you can send a range of emails to
take people through that journey to help
them to make the decision so what are
the different uses of email marketing it
can be used in relationship building
with existing customers who bought a
product for instance sent them a thank
you email it could be to boost brand
awareness it could be about promoting
various pieces of content it can help
you in generating leads or to promote or
Market your products and very important
you can use it to nurture leads today
we're going to talk about affiliate
marketing so let's jump right into it
and take a look inside an office
environment right now we have Chuck here
Chuck's doing a little bit of pacing
John walks in the office hey man what's
with all the pacing everything all right
Chuck responded hey I'm just worri that
I might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product I mean I've done
SEO I've done paid search I've done
email I done social man nothing's
working I got to come up with something
new ASAP well John responds hey don't
worry I think I've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need need affiliate
marketing so let's dig into affiliate
marketing so John's just taken over now
and he's going to let Chuck know
everything there is to know about
affiliate marketing so the first
question John answers for Chuck what is
affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if I'm selling a
product basic basically somebody else
sells that product for me I'm going to
pay that person a commission for selling
my product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these Merchants are doing or other
enties they're advertising your product
so they're advertising your product with
a referral so they're passing on their
own customers to you so that they can
buy your product and again The Exchange
is you give that website or other entity
a commission that's more or less what
affiliate marketing is so John's going
to have us take a look at each of these
components of affiliate marketing in
detail take it away John so John says
first we have the merchant AKA The Brand
the seller the Creator the founder the
owner the inspiration the innovator hey
this is the person who came up with this
brilliant idea This brilliant idea has
to get out there we're the merchant
we're trying to get this brilliant idea
out to the masses so this is the
component of affiliate marketing that
creates the product the merchant could
be anyone okay so it could be startups
to large multinational companies
International companies nonprofits
for-profits individuals independent
contractors Freelancers a group of
people who have a passion for something
okay it could be anybody there's no
limit the affiliate aka the publisher so
the affiliate is basically that
thirdparty website or entity which
promotes the merchants products and
tries to convince potential customers of
the merchants products value so this
affiliate going to represent the
merchant on their behalf and try and get
their clients to basically purchase that
particular Merchant's product so the
affiliate could be incentivized based on
you know registrations email sign up
sales and subscription so it doesn't
always come down to you know sales you
know if I'm just trying to get you know
build my email list then hey I can
incentivize that affiliate to push email
signups if I'm got this big you know
offline you know promotion that I'm
doing at this particular mall and I want
to get people there well I can get an
affiliate and incentivize that affiliate
to drive and help me drive registrations
for this event so it doesn't always have
to be sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
signups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and Affiliates together
together so that the affiliate can help
advertise and sell on behalf of the
merchant so with the affiliate Network
Merchants can use tools for tracking and
Reporting and processing payments for
Affiliates so really that affiliate
network is the glue that holds it all
together they're not just one to
introduce a merchant and affiliate they
offer it all so as a merchant you want
to be able to manage your Affiliates so
you're not going to have one affiliate
you're going to have multiple Affiliates
so you want to be able to use the
appropriate tools available to you in
the affiliate Network to see and track
how sales are going and when sales
happen okay or commissions happen you
want to be able to use that affiliate
Network to compensate that affiliate
appropriately and then finally the
customer customer aka the consumer is
the most important component of all of
this take it away John so the consumer
is the final and most important
component without customers to buy
products the merchant would not have any
revenue and the affiliate would not get
any commission so we need customers in
the age of digital marketing it is very
easy to get lost in the sea of
information if you are a beginner you
will probably spend a lot of time
reading and researching even if you are
an expert you will still need to keep up
to date and know what's going on in the
marketing world but how do you find the
time to do that how do you find the time
to stay on top of Trends and Innovations
we have compiled a list of 20 plus
digital marketing tools to help you make
your life easier some of these tools
might sound familiar to you and some
might sound new and interesting we
believe all of them have some value in
your life and can assist you in staying
on top of Trends hey everyone I'm Tushar
Bal welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel in this video we will understand
20 plus digital marketing tools to grow
your business in 2022 but before we
begin if you enjoy watching Tech related
content consider subscribing to our
YouTube channel and hitting that Bell
icon to stay tuned so without any
further delay let's get started with the
plan for today's session first we will
look at the research part next we will
explore tools to build or host a website
content is king So next we will have a
look at some of the best content
creation tools to grow your business
moving forward we will discuss designing
and Graphics tools once designing is is
done it's time to promote and hence we
will look at the best promotional tools
after that we will discuss some great
email marketing tools user behavior and
computer analysis tools and finally we
will end the session by understanding
the communication tools that will help
your business operate smoothly research
research is one of the most essential
parts of getting your business to the
next level it's what turns an idea into
a real business however it is hard to do
research without the right tools like
luckily there are many tools out there
that do the job perfectly here are just
few that you need to know about Uber
suggest Uber suggest is a free tool that
produces fresh keyword ideas it is among
the best free tools available on the
market however it has a Premium plan for
advanced features but it is best if you
are starting out and it has some good
features like you will get the search
volume for free keyword ideas and
content ideas Keyword Planner it is one
of the best fre tools and the best part
is that it's a Google product so that
the data can be trusted you can use
Google Keyword Planner to do keyword
research Google Keyword Planner will
show you the monthly search volume of
keywords and phrases the average cost
per click in your selected country and
how difficult it is to rank for the
keywords some of the best features are
you will get the custom time based
keyword data and get to know the
competition on that keyword HFS HFS is
one of the most advanced tool available
for keyword research it is also used for
competitor analysis rank tracking and
site auditing xf's main features are
geared towards marketer but you can also
use it to find keywords for Google
YouTube and Amazon the tool is paid but
suitable for businesses looking for
in-depth information it has some
features like rank tracker that will
help you know your existing website
ranking and the second one is alert you
will get get important information or
stats by mail after doing the research
part you need a website for your
business let's have a look at how to do
that the first step in creating a
website is to find a place to host it
there are many options out there and
depending on what your site will be used
for you may need different tools web
hosting tools have evolved to meet the
online communities need better it can be
challenging to select the right one
through many options here are the few of
the best tools available on the market
WordPress it will help you create your
website by just drag and dropping no
coding is required also it has a lot of
plugins that can be used according to
your website needs blogger you can
create a beautiful blog using blogger
for free and it is also has free themes
which you can use still it is always
recommended that you use tools like
WordPress to build your website because
businesses need a web website with lot
of functionalities and WordPress makes
this process easier the website requires
hosting as the next tool we have is
hostinger you need to purchase a domain
and hosting to host a website there are
other companies also available that you
can use to host your site such as
GoDaddy HostGator Etc hostinger provides
automatic backups that will ensure that
your website data is secured it allows
you to create unlimited subdomain which
is also necessary for a business website
for free hosting and free domains you
can use Infinity free but for a business
website it is always recommended to go
with the paid hosting because this will
give your customer a good experience
when they visit your website but for a
beginner just wanting to learn how
website hosting works you can use
Infinity free every Business website and
its social media platform need content
and content is the oxygen of the
internet there is no surviving without
it but meeting the demand of a Content
hungry World often means that you are
forced to pull your hair out only to
throw more into the fire from research
to Creation to distribution content is
now 24x7 job requiring many internal
resources or costly outsourced help if
you are looking to cut down the cost and
streamline your efforts here are some
content creation tools to take your
business to the next level headline it
it is an AI tool that will create a
landing page automatically no writing
designing and coding is required you
need to give information about the
product and it is also has built-in
templates to use it became famous
because of this feature but now it is
upgrade it and you will see a lot of
other features that will help you create
excellent content it is a paid tool but
you can try its free version pepper type
it is a onstop AI solution tool for all
content needs and the best part is you
will get 10,000 World limit to try out
this fantastic tool the specialty of
this tool is that it allows you to
create content for specific social media
platforms and long form
content grammarly grammarly is a free
online tool that find mistakes in your
writing and suggest improvements as you
write grammarly will underline any
mistakes you have made and offer
suggestions on how to fix them
additionally it has a plager ISM Checker
and a punctuation
checker however for additional features
you need to go with grammarly premium
the best way to create excellent content
is to have good visuals this is why we
have listed the best designing tools
that you can use to get stock images and
videos canva you can design your website
using canva for free it is the best tool
to make your website content more
engaging it is a simple drag and drop
tool that allows you to create beautiful
Graphics Flyers infographics social
media post and more you can also use it
to create more engaging images for your
post furthermore it gives you free
templates and allows you to collaborate
with your business team using team
functionality pixabay pixabay is a free
website or a creative community that
shares copyright free photos
illustrations music and videos all pixa
content are licensed under the pixa
license
you can use them without asking for
permission or crediting the artist even
for commissional
purposes you can download these stock
images videos musics and illustration
without signing up shutter stock
although it also comes with the same
feature the key difference is that it is
paid you might wonder why to use this
shutter stock since we already have a
free tool like pixabay well it depends
on your business needs there are some
images and stock footage that you will
only only find on C stock in addition C
stock has powerful editing tools and
custom siiz options that attract people
now we have a better understanding of
the content part in order to attract
more visitors the content needs to be
promoted the following tools will help
you promote your business Drive traffic
to your website convert visitors into
leads build brand awareness Etc Google
ads Google ads are a powerful tool that
can help you reach your target audience
it is small but significant step towards
online Success Through many people
believe that Google ads are not as
effective as they used to be there are
still more benefits than drawbacks the
only thing you need to know how to use
it your website can be advertised via
Google ads and your product and services
can be promoted on YouTube it has an
excellent feature lead form extension
that allow user to provide their contact
details directly through the ad without
visiting your landing page additionally
life events targeting for example
graduating from a college is also a
great feature since it helps you reach
the correct type of audience Facebook
ads manager it allows you to run
Facebook and Instagram ads and it's an
excellent way to promote your business a
feature like Facebook analytics will
give you a good grasp of data feature
like audience Insight will better
understand who is interested in your
product and services Google ads and
Facebook ads requ require you to spend
money on ads by setting up a daily or a
custom budet buas suumo is a Content
marketing tool to help you find the best
ways of engaging creating and spreading
content across social and search
channels two of the best feature is
finding an influencer that will help you
to find the right influencer and a
Content Discovery feature which will
help you to discover new content ideas
email marketing tools are the most
effective means to stay in touch with
your customers you can nurture lead
leads rearrange with your audience and
build a subscriber base through email
businesses today recognize the
importance of email and marketers are
investing heavily in email marketing
tools however in the overwhelming sea of
email marketing tools finding the right
fit can be tricky we have selected some
of the best email marketing tools to
help your business get started and grow
through
2022 MailChimp MailChimp is a
comprehensive marketing platform that
lets you keep track off and communicate
with your clients customers and other
interested parties but it is popular
because of its email Services there is a
free plan of MailChimp the free plan is
often more than enough for small
businesses up to 2,000 subscribers can
be added and 12,000 emails can be sent a
month it supports multiple integration
to integrate other thirdparty softwares
and MailChimp also allows you to update
or remove the subscriber profiles which
is also one of the best feature of
MailChimp send in blue it is very
similar to MailChimp both have excellent
and similar features when it comes to
email Services one unique feature of
send in blue is that it has a option of
a drag and drop Builder that is
accessible by mobile analysis and
optimization businesses need to analyze
and optimize their processes to grow
furthermore you should analyze the data
to develop a solution to the problems in
your industry several tools can be Ben
beneficial here let's discuss that
Google search console this tool will
help you understand how your website
performs on Google searches by ranking
on top you will have higher chances of
attracting more visitors the index
coverage report will help you understand
which web page have problems moreover it
has a very useful URL inspection tool
which gives information about Google's
index page version vid IQ many YouTubers
majorly use it to analyze their
performance perment on YouTube and
optimize their Channel if you are
looking to rank your video on YouTube
you need to optimize the title
description and tags this tool helps you
to do that the tool includes a thumbnail
generator that lets you create
customized thumbnails that generate good
views and hit as Trend alerts which will
notify you by email of popular content
Google analytics using Google analytics
you can track the traffic on your
website and find out where your visitor
are coming from it also allows you to
track your sales performance and traffic
sources Google analytics is a tool that
will let you know if your website is
performing well and also if you need to
make some changes to improve its
performance it has outstanding features
like funnel analysis and smart goals a
funnel is a method for determining which
steps are necessary to achieve the
desired outcomes and with smart goals
you can identify and count the most
engaged users on your website user
Behavior user Behavior tools help you
understand user behavior on the website
user Behavior tools are very effective
tools used in digital marketing to track
the behavior of visitors and make the
business more effective below are the
some of the user Behavior tools used in
digital marketing hotjar hotjar is an
inside tool that lets you analyze your
customer behavior and get feedback to
understand them better and come up with
new business strategies to grow your
business this tool gives you visual
feedback which you won't find in other
tools and it also offer surveys which is
also a unique feature of hja smart look
it is mostly similar to hodja but it has
some additional features like
customizable dashboard and conversion
funnel which means the visualization of
how people follow the path competitor
analysis many businesses start their
competitive study when planning their
digital marketing strategy and then
abandon it it is essential to make
adjustments after competitor analysis
and use great tools here are some of the
best the tool is completely paid you can
use this tool to improve your PPC
campaign as it gives you insight into
what your competitors are doing keywords
can also be imported as well as
downloaded social blade it is used for
social media monitoring and influencer
tracking for example you can get lot of
information about the performance of
other competitors and how they are doing
on YouTube and other social media
channels the best part is that many
features are available in the free plan
similar web it is also an excellent tool
to analyze competitors website traffic
and you can also get the Google Play and
Apple App Store data HF we already
covered this in the research category
but we wanted to mention it here because
href will also be viewed as one of the
best tools for an analyzing
competitors communication starting and
building a successful business require
better communication within your team we
must ensure that our task has been
clearly communicated to the team so that
we will be able to perform the work as
we intended thus one needs a tool to
accomplish that so now let's check out
some of the best tools for communication
slack the app is a chat room that brings
together all of your team's
Communication in one place meaning there
is a no longer a need to use email Skype
or multi- chat room apps slack can be
used with both work and personal
accounts and it can benefit businesses
in several different ways Microsoft
teams it is also similar to slack but it
offers unlimited app integration and
unlimited chat messages there are free
plans for both but you can upgrade if
your business need aren't met here what
you have learned so far initially we
discussed research then tools to build
and host the website next we discussed
content creation and graphic designing
tools after that we discussed tools that
will help in the promotion and then the
email marketing tools after that we
discussed analyis and optimization tools
next we discussed user behavior and
competitor analysis tools and finally we
discussed the communication tools if you
are an aspiring digital marketer then
have a look at simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing 2 years of experience is
preferred so hurry up and enroll Now
find the cost Link in the description
box today we're going to cover digital
marketing interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's going to work so we
broke out a few questions and answers uh
in different categories a lot of you are
going to be interviewing for some jobs
out there and some of the jobs maybe an
SEO manager or search engine marketing
manager or email marketing manager or
content marketing manager or social
media manager so we broke up those
questions into those areas and so that's
what we're going to do we're going to
start with sea we're going to go through
some questions and I'm going to explain
the answers to those questions so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back back
to as soon as possible so let's get
started we're going to start with SEO
search engine optimization we're going
to go through a series of questions and
I'm going to answer those questions for
you okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you taken or listen
to my SEO courses on YouTube for SEO we
we talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put I mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to siteb we're
going to basically tell Google Bing and
some of these other search engines hey
go ahead and follow that link now I know
follow is just the opposite so no follow
link doesn't allow the search engine
crawlers to follow it so if we have a
link on our site s site a pointing to
site B we can put a no follow tag in
there and what that's going to do it's
going to signal to the Crawlers hey
don't follow this link so in the end if
the Crawlers don't follow the link then
there's not going to be any link juice
past and so Google is not going to give
you credit or give that site credit for
having a link pointing to it or pointing
to another site or from another site and
so it's all about linking so we can
control if there's links on our site
whether we want the Crawlers to
recognize those or not simply with no
follow tags so just a reminder link use
is the reputation or Equity passed from
one website to another so if you have a
link on another website and that website
is of high quality meaning their page
Authority their domain Authority is high
they have a lot of content you know
they're not spammy they're really rich
and they're relevant then you may want
to make sure that the link pointing from
that site to your site is a no follow so
that way that Google can recognize the
link from that site to your site and
basically that reputation is going to be
passed on to you okay so that's a do
follow versus a no follow and why would
we do a no follow well it depends it
really depends a lot of social media
platforms like Facebook have no follows
if you have a lot of content you may not
want to be pushing out a lot of do
follows it could actually look bad from
an external linking standpoint and so a
lot of sites are really particular about
who they want to pass link juice on to
and give credit for the link so it's a
business decision at the end of the day
there's really no hard fast rule here
except from an SEO perspective if I have
a site and I have a lot of external
links pointing outward to other sites
I'm going to be particular about who I
allow the search engine to follow and
what links I allow not to follow okay so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the hre
notice the no follow has the the tag
appended to it the hre tag with a no
follow so if the search engine's
crawling your site and they see that no
follow there they're not going to follow
that link and vice versa if there's a
link on another site pointing to yours
and there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so 301 redirects tell users in the
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the key word here permanently so
permanently moved we're going to explain
that in a minute so it's just moved from
one page to another and so if we don't
have a page anymore but we have a new
page let's just say you built a new
website with new URLs you want to make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page with a 31 redirect so if a 301
redirect is permanent then a 302 is
temporary so we want the search Eng
to recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
Google to not keep that page in its
search engine rankings because it's
temporary so why would Google want to
keep a temporary page or even a page
that is pointing to another page on a
temporary basis so they may remove both
pages from its index okay but if we have
something permanent in place Google may
say okay this page is permanently
linking to another page or redirecting
to another page therefore it's stable
it's permanent we're going to keep that
new page in the index and eventually
remove the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect he so question three
why are backlinks important in SEO well
we kind of hinted on that a bit with the
no follow because if we have a link from
another website pointing to ours and
that link from that other website is
really relevant and and it has a high
page and domain Authority then it's
going to benefit us and so backlinks are
important because if we have backlinks
from high quality sites it's going to
improve the credibility of our site
especially if it's a do follow tag so
the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a Lion Share of the
traffic for certain keywords that our
pages are found for and if our pages are
found and getting traffic then because
we have increased rankings we're likely
going to have increased traffic and then
it's just a snowball effect so more
traffic leads to more engagement and
conversions so the whole idea for SEO is
remember you have an onpage strategy and
an off-page strategy building external
links is part of an off-page SEO
strategy and we want to make sure that
you know we are relevant in the form of
a link or in the form of content on
other high quality sites being on a high
quality site only benefits us because
again increases our D domain Authority
Google sees this is more relevant
therefore pages are going to benefit by
ranking higher and therefore when we
rank higher we get more traffic so it's
a snowball effect so having backlinks is
important because it snowballs all the
way through to conversions okay so what
are the best practices to rank your
videos on YouTube this is a great
question really great question given the
importance of videos especially with SEO
cuz videos are found YouTube in itself
is a search engine so if we have a video
how are we going to get it to rank on
YouTube well first things first you
never want to put a video out there and
want it to rank if it's not engaging or
informative so make sure you go ahead
and follow the best practices of having
engaging in informative content in your
video now once you have that video in
place you want to optimize it and then
some of the key factors for optimizing
the video are you want to choose a title
that has high search volume and low
difficulty just as you would keyword for
example for web page you want to choose
a title with a keyword in it that has
high volume and low
difficulty IE low competition okay so
you want a nice ratio there and you know
when you want to choose a title it's
going to get people to watch the video
too so it's not all about just choosing
a title just for the sake of high volume
you also have to choose something that's
relevant that's going to be catchy as
well and then with that title goes the
description so you want a description
that's very relevant to your title okay
because most people aren't going to
click on a video just for the sake of a
title they're going to want to probably
get a sneak peek via the the description
of what it is so again you want to
optimize that description but make sure
the description is is just as snazzy as
the title okay you also want to use
accurate and relevant video tags just as
you would on Twitter or Facebook tag
these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
going to grab somebody's attention and
then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
Twitter and Facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via
hashtagging and then this goes about
saying you did all the work created a
really great video it's engaging it's
informative you optimized it feel free
to promote your video video on other
social media platforms okay don't just
stick with YouTube per se so the benefit
here is if you post it on Facebook or
LinkedIn or whatever platform of your
choice and it gets engagement people
click on the link go to YouTube they're
going to like it and then other people
are going to see that engagement they're
going to see how many people liked it or
how many subscribers you have so promote
your videos to help you with the ranking
of the video on YouTube so that does
play into it so go ahead and promote it
so other people can watch it like it
comment Etc and that's going to engage
other people to want to do the same so
what is mobile first indexing this is a
really important and timely question
mobile first indexing means Google's
just using mobile friendly content for
indexing and ranking websites so in
other words Google for example has two
Bots they have the traditional desktop
bot and they have a smart SM phone bot
and eventually everybody that has a
website is going to be migrated over to
the smartphone bot and so with that
smartphone bot goes to your website and
starts crawling what do you think
they're looking for their smartphone bot
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
mobile device Google's not going to grab
that content so you want to make sure
it's mobile friendly so it gets indexed
and so if your website has a responsive
design Google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asked you this question you could even
take it a step further and say look I'm
going to measure how friendly my my
website is for mobile devices in Google
search console because Google search
console has a report that will show you
what pages on your website are not
mobile friendly and it's not a guarantee
but I could tell you if I'm Google and
I'm crawling your site with my
smartphone bot and that page or one of
my pages is not mobile friendly I'm
probably not going to index it or rank
it so you want to leverage that report
in Google search cont conso to see what
pages are mobile friendly so that's a
little bonus for you to really impress
the interviewer who ask you this
question because how are you going to
know if one of your pages is mobile
friendly or not if you don't look at a
report so keep an eye on Google search
consoles mo mobile usability report okay
number six list down the most important
local SEO ranking factors okay so
organic local ranking is just as
important important as anything else in
organic search because if you have a
local business you want to use the likes
of say Google my business to show up
when somebody types in you know looking
for a florist or you looking for a
coffee shop so what you want to do is
you want to create a web page for every
product and service and you also want to
opt for your business listings on Google
my business and and there are plenty of
other local business directories out
there like y for example or Bing even
has one so go ahead and also make sure
you have a business listing as well but
since Google in the United States has a
huge market share you want to start with
Google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so you want to
make sure that that's current and
consistent so if you have a number on
your website make sure it's the same
number on Google m my business okay you
can embed a Google map on your website
you could certainly optimize the
metatags and content not only on your
web pages but within your Google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
I mentioned yel and then also just as
important op for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews the H you have
the better off you are okay so I always
say this with or with local search three
of the main factors and showing up for
local search on say Google is obviously
the keyword the second is the proximity
of where that person is and then third
is the reviews so you can't really
control the proximity but you can
control the keyword and you can control
the reviews to some degree so work hard
at getting reviews for your business but
at the same time you can certainly work
in some key words let's just say for
your product and service pages on your
website but also Al you can translate
that over to Google my business okay so
working in those keywords making sure
your your number your address your name
they're all consistent and and really
just spreading your the the business out
on other directories that's really all
these are really key factors for local
SEO okay so question number seven how to
avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
SEO 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this in
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember 301's
are permanent we can also use what they
call a canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and then the third option is opt for
preferred domain and Google search
console okay so if you have multiple no
names make sure you set up a primary one
in search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three I would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's going
to sit on the page it's going to alert
Google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you can
just tell the search engines hey this is
the original page or you can go through
search console okay number eight what
are the tactics to increase a web page
speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a side
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible what I mean by
simple as possible really I mean hey use
a simple website design don't get overly
creative if you will most websites all
websites have images you're not going to
be able to get around that but just make
sure you optimize your images in other
words don't have such a large image size
if you don't need something very large
don't have it okay you want to improve
server response time and what do we mean
by that well your site's sitting on a
server somewhere you can own that server
or you can be renting it out from say
Amazon web services or or let's just say
GoDaddy as your register they also have
web hosting well if you have it on say
GoDaddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and at
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have a an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server response is
slow that's going to slow down
everything else in terms of loading in
the browser and that's not going to be
good for SEO okay optimize your code
what we mean by optim minifying when we
see minifying we mean get rid of some of
the Redundant code if you have CSS you
know get rid of chop some of the get rid
of the JavaScript you're not using so
that's what we mean by optimizing code
reduce redirects okay ideally just want
to have one redirect in place you don't
want to create a daisy chain so to speak
of redirecting and redirecting after
that that's never going to bode well and
it's going to slow things down as well
enable browser caching so if you enable
browser caching basically if somebody
comes back to the page they've been on
say two days ago they're probably going
to see a cach version of that page and
then opt for the content delivery
Network as well so these are some of the
ways to reduce page speed now if you're
curious about the page speed of your
website you can always go to Google's
page speed insights tool and all you
have to do is just Google page speed
insights or even just something generic
like Google page speed and you're going
to get this tool page speed insights and
all you need to do is just plug in a URL
when you plug in the URL Google's going
to analyze the URL for both mobile and
desktop and so here we could see Google
gives a score so we could see the score
for mobile and we can see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here I could see some of the issues
that the site may be having in terms of
page low time for their desktop if I
flip over to mobile you know here I
could see some other issues for example
they have a server static assets with
efficient cash policy now if you're not
sure what the heck that means you can
always just click on it and you can see
some specifics here and or you can just
always Google it as well uh here you got
the reduce the impact of third party
code okay so that's another thing uh
reduce JavaScript execution time so
again going back to a lot of some of the
comments we met about coding okay some
sometimes too much code or code not
functioning as well as it should will
tend to slow down the site okay so you
can use PP insights you can always get a
glimpse of how pages are loading simply
by also going to for example Google
Analytics under Behavior okay you can go
to site speed and if you click on
overview okay Google what Google does is
they do a sampling of pages over time
and in this case based on 89 Page views
they have an average page load time and
so you can get a sense of how quick
specific Pages load your site overall
simply by looking at the site speed
overview report in Google analytics to
get a sense of how quick your pages are
loading now there's certain factors that
do affect load time so obviously the way
the page is built with the code the
images Etc but also the browser each
browser loads differently okay so you
want to take a look at it by browser
also by country every country has a
different network you can be in the
United States and have worse network
service than you do say in you know Co
Ivory Coast in Africa Okay so really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings in Google analytics
and you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools at your disposal one
Google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual Target short tail and
longtail keywords okay so remember short
tail are usually one to two keywords
very Broad in nature longtail keywords
maybe three four keywords in a query or
maybe an entire sentence those are
considered longtail keywords so usually
short tail keywords have higher volume
but also higher competition longer tail
keywords usually have lower uh volume
but also lower competition but the great
thing about longtail keywords the
conversion rate will tend to be a little
bit higher than say a short tail because
it's less vague and more specific so you
can use short tail keywords if you're
trying to drive a lot of visitors
because those keywords are going to be
vague or Broad in nature longtail
keywords are used for targeted Pages
such as product pages and articles so if
you have a specific product with a long
name you can certainly optimize that
page for that product name again the
product name may have low volume but if
somebody types in exactly that product
name you show up the chance of you them
converting are going to be very high so
you don't have to always be that
specific with a product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say longtail where hey maybe
you're just toned in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care of a lot about the traffic
you just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus Focus while developing
a website so we're talking in terms of
SEO okay so if somebody asked me this
question in an interview what am I going
to focus on while developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to be indexed with Google
smartphone bod so mobile usability is
very important so we need to make sure
our website is responsive for mobile
just some basic practices when it comes
to site Arch exure navigation we want to
have a simple URL structure okay no
overly cumbersome the navigation should
simply be clean and neat okay if you
have five products okay maybe you have
uh in your navigation you have something
called products with all five listed or
you have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat easy for somebody
to find the the rule of thumb is if it's
good for the end user probably going to
be good for Google but if complicated
for the end User it's probably going to
be complicated ated for Google you
always want to create a Sit map now what
is that sitemap a sitemap is simply just
a formatted file with to that's includes
all your URLs and assets your images and
your videos they're going to be sitting
on your server as well so you want
Google or these these Bots to be able to
find your pages and assets and by the
way you want to take it a step further
and make sure you upload that site map
which is sitting in the root directory
meaning
domain.com
sitemap.xml okay you want to take that
sitemap and make sure you input that
sitap location in Google search console
that way Google search console has a
oneway ticket to grab the elements in
the sitemap another important element to
focus on while developing a WIP side is
having a robot's text file and all A
robot's text file is it's like a lock I
always say to a house so if you lock a
door in your house nobody's going to be
able to get in that door so it's all a
robots text file is you're telling
Google and these other Bots that are
coming acrw your site what's locked and
what's not locked meaning what they have
access to what they don't have access to
so you want to be able to make sure you
have a robot's text file if you're
trying to not index specific pages of
your website because if you tell Google
don't crawl these Pages or this
directory they're not going to get
crawled if they don't get crawled
they're not going to get indexed so
robots text file is an important element
to focus on while you're developing your
website and while you're developing your
website it could be on a you know in a
directory just called new website so you
probably want to have new website as the
directory in the robots text file and
just to let Google know don't go into
this directory because it's my new
website I'm not ready to go live yet so
you don't want it indexed so there are a
lot of reasons to have robots text files
that's the main reason sitap you want
Google to get these pages and assets
quickly okay you want to make sure that
your site architecture navigation is in
order you want to make sure your site is
mobile friendly and you also want to
make sure you have content on your
website that's the key because that's
what's going to keep people on the
website and engaged and when I say
content I don't necessarily just mean
words I also mean videos I also mean
images you know something interactive
okay you want to keep people engaged
that's the key behind it trust me if an
end user finds your side engaging Google
is likely going to find your side
engaging okay so those are good brownie
points to bring up if somebody asks you
this question in an interview so just a
recap here it's important to have a
better site structure so the Bots can
easily access and IND content okay with
a responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time user spends on your website
which may improve your site's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine Bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where they
located along with the videos and images
okay and then the robots text just
instructs the search engine crawlers to
understand what pages should not be
indexed okay this is simply just a text
file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house so
here we wrap up this digital marketing
course for beginners if you have any
questions
feel free to add them in the comment
section our experts will be happy to
help thanks for watching this video
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here